So, mal gucken, wer der Erste im Chat heute ist.
Chatge.
Omega Chatge.
Der freut sich halt wieder am Start.
Der ist immer als erstes da.
Ist er auch nicht.
Ich frag mich echt, wie er das macht.
Mal kurz die Emotes ein bisschen verschieben.
Verschenke ein Abo, um Platz 1 einzunehmen.
So, so.
Der Chat.
Guck.
Es ist echt blöd, dass man das nicht mehr im normalen Twitch-Chat einfach entfernen kann.
Ich meine, ich habe FFZ installiert.
Da kann man das irgendwie ausblenden.
Aber es ist trotzdem blöd.
Was da oben immer rumgammelt.
Leute, ich habe heute eine News gelesen.
Und zwar.
Pass mal auf.
Richtige Keck-Welt-News.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, das ist ja fast die Baldur's Gate 3-Story in Real Life.
Wartet mal.
Wurm im Gehirn.
Ja.
Wartet mal.
Äh, News.
In Australien, Alter.
In Australien bringt dich alles um.
Guckt euch das an.
Die Australier, ich weiß nicht.
Da bringt dich alles um.
Schlangen, Frösche, Spinnen, Kängurus, Krokodile.
Alles.
In Australien bringt dich einfach alles um.
Und neuerdings gibt es in Australien auch Würmer im Gehirn.
Muss ich mir vorstellen.
Da haben sie irgendeiner Frau, die hatte, die hat, ähm.
Die hatte erst, die hatte erst Bauchschmerzen, Atemprobleme und irgendwann Vergesslichkeit.
Und dann haben sie ihr so ein Bild vom, vom, vom, vom Innenleben, vom Schädel gemacht.
Und haben festgestellt, dass sich da drin was bewegt.
Weil die Änderung von einem Bild zum anderen, ich weiß nicht, ob es da, ne, Tagschauter, kein Bild, war zu groß.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann festgestellt.
Dass, dass die einen, ich glaube, acht oder zehn Zentimeter großen Wurm im Kopf hatte, Alter.
Der dann irgendwie im Gehirn rumgefressen hat und so.
So richtig abartig, ja.
Ist, ist, ist fast ein bisschen wie die Baldur's Gate 3 Story.
Nur, dass sie wahrscheinlich nicht zu irgendeinem Mind Flayer mutiert.
Hat, ja, ja, ja.
Die haben den rausoperiert.
Die haben, die haben den, den Kopf da aufgemacht und den, und den Wurm rausgeholt.
Und dass das, dass das besonders eklig ist, merkt man daran.
Dass die Ärztin, die sie operiert hat, gesagt hat, dass sie das eklig fand.
Und ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn Chirurgen was eklig finden, dann muss das wirklich eklig sein.
Also, wenn es euch gefallen hat.
Ich bin täglich am BG3 spielen.
Also, wir haben noch nicht viel weiter gespielt als im Stream.
Wir können ruhig demnächst noch weiter, weiter bashen, Alter.
Ich meine, meine, meine Role-Playing-Skills halten sich in Grenzen.
Aber.
Muss, muss trotzdem gelootet und gebasht werden.
So, ja, wie immer.
Ja, und.
Also, es ist echt krass in Australien.
So, und im Nachhinein kam dann raus.
Wie gesagt, ich will jetzt euch nicht den Artikel vorlesen.
Das sage ich bloß kurz jetzt.
Der steht da aber sicherlich auch bei der Tagesschau irgendwie drin.
Die hatte den, glaube ich, 16 Monate oder so.
Im.
Im Körper.
Den Wurm.
Und die hatte erst Wagenprobleme, Bauchschmerzen.
Äh, Verdauungsprobleme, ähm, Atemprobleme.
Und irgendwann hat sie, hat sie Konzentrationsprobleme und Gedächtnisverlust und sowas gehabt.
Und.
Das kam daher.
Je nachdem, wo der Wurm gerade war.
Die hat den wahrscheinlich zu sich genommen mit irgendwelchem selbst geerntet, erntetem, äh, Grünzeug aus dem Wald.
Oder aus dem Busch irgendwie in Australien.
Dann war der zuerst im Magen.
So.
Dann hat der da im Magen rumgewurmt.
Und dann hatte sie erst, da hatte sie halt, da, da hatte sie halt Magenprobleme und Verdauungsprobleme.
Dann ist der langsam hochgewandert, so durch die Lunge, Alter, da hat sie Atemprobleme gehabt.
Und irgendwann hoch bis ins Hirn.
Und dann hat sie, hat sie Vergesslichkeits, äh, da hat sie, war sie, wurde sie vergesslich und hatte Konzentrationsprobleme.
Und dann haben sie erst gemerkt, da ist ein Wurm im Hirn, also echt, echt krasse Story.
Normalerweise lese ich sowas gar nicht, aber das war echt.
Gerade weil ich gerade Baldur's Gate 3 spiele, das ist echt, das ist echt heftig, ja.
Naja.
Aber wie gesagt, in Australien bringt dich eh alles um.
Zwei Meter nebenan Weg gelaufen, also auf dem Weg ist auch egal.
Die haben ja, die haben ja da alles.
Die haben, die haben Schildkröten oder so, die dir Finger abbeißen können, eben alles.
Also in Australien bringt dich echt alles um.
Ey, ja, hat er ja wohl, hat er ja wohl.
Hat er wohl, hat er, der hat ja nicht einfach nur abgechillt da oben.
Wird ja auch gesagt, dass ein Großteil der Katzenbesitzer einen Parasit im Körper haben.
Naja.
Also.
Ja, bestimmt, bestimmt hast du keinen 10 oder 8 Zentimeter langen,
weiß gar nicht wie lang der jetzt wirklich war, wie 8 oder 10 Zentimeter.
Im Kopf.
Ja, also was das angeht, die haben, ja, Südamerika ist auch so.
Aber Australien ist, glaube ich, das krasseste.
Die haben alles.
Giftliche Schlangen, Frösche, Krokodile.
Spinnen, egal, es bringt dich, bringt dich alles um.
Ich hab, ich hab letztens in irgendeinem Beitrag gelesen, dass, also in Australien haben die auch total viele solche, äh, so, so, so, so, wie, wie heißt denn das, so, so, so, so Notfall, Notfallstationen für Schlangenbisse und sowas.
So, und ich hab, ich hab letztens in irgendeinem Artikel gelesen, dass die australischen Ural, übelst random Thema, ich weiß, okay, aber.
Äh, dass die australischen Ureinwohner, wenn sie von einer Schlange gebissen wurden, da konnten die halt noch nicht in irgendeine Notfallaufnahme oder so fahren, die haben ihr Bein genommen und die haben Loch, die haben ein Loch gebuddelt in die Erde und haben hier ihr Bein in das Loch gesteckt und ganz fest mit Erde zugemacht, bis das wieder gut war.
So, und das sollte wohl dazu dienen, also, don't try this at home, das hab ich irgendwo gelesen, ja, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt und keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist, ja.
Zählt's jetzt bloß trotzdem.
Zumindest, die haben ja ihr Bein in ein Loch gesteckt, in der Erde, haben das ganz fest mit Erde zugebuddelt, da, wo sie mit, von einer Schlange gebissen wurden.
Das hat erstens dazu geführt, dass sich das Gift nicht so, nicht so sehr im Körper verbreitet hat und dass das Bein nicht mehr so gut durch, durchblutet wurde und deswegen das Gift irgendwie nicht so effektiv war.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, ja.
Tja.
Aber in Australien ist halt echt, ist halt echt alles, alles vorbei.
Wenn dich da irgendwas beißt, Instant Dead, ja, das kann ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dauern.
Manche, also ich hab keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, ob das stimmt, aber das kann ja durchaus sein.
Das braucht ja alles auch ein bisschen und es hält dafür auch manchmal drei Tage oder länger, bis das, bis das alles irgendwie überwunden ist.
Und dann hatten die halt drei Tage ihr, ihr, ihr Bein in irgendeinem Erdloch stecken.
Wo wir übrigens gerade bei Beinen in irgendeinem Erdloch stecken sind, hat das nicht so wirklich was mit Beinen und Erdlöchern zu tun?
Wenn jetzt einer zum ersten Mal im Stream ist, der denkt sich auch, keck, wait, was, was labert da?
Ähm, zumindest eine, eine Sache, ich hab heute, ich bin normalerweise jetzt ja die letzten, die letzten Tage immer rennen gegangen, jeden zweiten Tag.
Ähm, das längste, was ich bisher gelaufen hab, war, weil tatsächlich ja immer mal wieder welche Fragen, ich erzähl euch das, ich hab eine neue, einen, einen neuen, äh, Rekord, was Reichweite angeht.
Und, äh.
Das war, lass mich mal kurz gucken, Kalender.
Ich bin 7,74 Kilometer gerannt, gerannt, in einer Stunde, eine Minute und 15 Sekunden.
Allerdings bin ich diesmal absichtlich nicht so schnell gerannt, wie ich konnte.
148 Puls im Durchschnitt und 7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer.
Und, warum ich euch das erzähle, ist folgendes.
Das war vor, das war am 28., also das war am 28. um 9 Uhr, also sprich, das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, zweieinhalb Tage her.
Was ist da die Pace?
Ja, 7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer.
Oder willst du, oder willst du die Geschwindigkeit wissen?
Die Geschwindigkeit ist, ähm, 7,6 kmh.
7,6 kmh und 7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer im Durchschnitt.
Zumindest, ja.
Ja, mittlerweile kann ich tatsächlich rennen, man glaubt's gar nicht.
So, und zumindest, zumindest, warum ich das, 10 Kilometer 55 Minuten, das ist ziemlich gut.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Unter 60 Minuten 10 Kilometer, das ist ziemlich gut.
Zumindest, warum ich, warum ich das erzähle, ist, normalerweise habe ich mir, renne ich ja jeden zweiten Tag.
Aber ich bin heute nicht, ich bin heute nicht gerannt, weil.
Ich, ähm, mir hat nach diesen 7,7, runden wir es mal auf.
7,8 Kilometern.
Hat mir echt, das links und rechts, so ein bisschen das Knie wehgetan.
Gerade beim Treppe runterlaufen.
Die Wade, Alter.
Ich sag euch.
Äh, und am schlimmsten war mein Schienbein, Alter.
Das Schienbein hat wehgetan.
Also, und da hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Ich mach mal lieber einen Tag länger Pause, bevor ich, bevor ich weiter renne.
Morgen früh werd ich wieder meine Runde rennen, so diese Standard 6 Kilometer.
Runde.
Aber es ist wirklich ein Unterschied.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Äh, machen wir das mal mit dem Wurm weg.
Es ist wirklich ein Unterschied, ob du 7,8 oder 6 Kilometer rennst.
Also, 6, 6 Kilometer packe ich mittlerweile easy.
Und auch ohne, dass mir großartig was weh tut danach.
Ich meine, vielleicht ein bisschen, ja, ein bisschen kaputt den restlichen Tag über.
So, beim Treppe runterlaufen und hochlaufen.
Aber, ansonsten kein Problem.
Aber die 7,7 waren schon, da hatten wir wirklich mehr.
Also, was mir ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht hat, ist, dass mir mein Schienbein weh tut.
Weil ich meine.
Weil, ich meine, am Schienbein hast du ja keine großartigen Muskeln oder so.
Und wenn ich so, aufs Schienbein, jetzt geht's wieder.
Jetzt merke ich nichts mehr.
Aber, wenn ich aufs Schienbein drauf gedrückt habe, gestern noch.
An manchen Stellen hat es wirklich gezogen.
So, wie wenn man einen blauen Fleck hätte.
Kennt, ihr kennt doch, ihr kennt doch bestimmt, jeder kennt doch das Gefühl, wenn man einen blauen Fleck hat.
Und da aus Versehen ein bisschen drauf drückt.
So hat sich das bei mir am Schienbein angefühlt.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay.
Das ist keine allzu gute Sache.
Dass dir dein Schienbein weh tut.
Nach dem Rennen.
Mach mal lieber einen Tag länger Pause.
Und das hat auch geholfen.
Heute ist es schon wieder viel besser.
Ich bin vorher plus, ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden langsam gelaufen.
Also nicht gejoggt.
Also wirklich langsam gelaufen.
Ein bisschen hier durch den Wald.
Und ein bisschen Bewegung am Tag muss ja sein.
Ey, du hast gegoogelt.
Du hast gegoogelt.
Ich hab auch gegoogelt.
Das nennt man nicht so.
Das nennt man nur so, wenn die Knochenhaut entzündet ist.
Und dann hast du andere Schmerzen, dann hast du andere Probleme.
Und das merkst du bei Belastung auch.
Ne, ne.
Das ist einfach überlastend und überanstrengend.
Natürlich muss man gucken, dass es nicht noch schlimmer wird.
Ja, das ist klar.
Sarchin Silva schreibt, war heute bei einem Unternehmen in der zweiten Runde.
Quintessenz, der Geschäftsführer, wollte mein Gesicht sehen und meine Stimme hören.
Ja gut, das kann ich auch verstehen.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Bei einem Bewerbungskandidat.
Bewerbungskandidat und so.
Irgendwann würde ich den auch mal sehen wollen.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Termin ging sieben Minuten.
Moment.
Man hat immer noch keine Ansage gemacht, was ich bei der Stelle verdienen werde und Co.
Aber man meldet sich nächste Woche.
Hatte ich ein erstes Mal bei einem Unternehmen bei mir im Stadtteil.
72,5k wollen sie mir zahlen.
Weil ich dann mehr als der IT-Leiter verdienen würde.
Ich weiß nicht.
Welche Branche und ich weiß nicht, welche Region, aber für einen Leiter IT erscheinen mir 72k dann doch ein bisschen wenig.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, das ist eine Position, die gibt es einmalig pro Unternehmen.
Also.
Das ist das.
Das ist ja quasi die höchste Stufe, die man im Karriere-Crime erreichen kann.
Und dafür lohnt sich ja auch jetzt nicht wirklich den krassen Karriere-Crime hinzulegen.
Also Stripes.
Fünf.
Fünf Minuten vierzig pro Kilometer ist ziemlich gut.
Ja und?
Ich meine, das musst du jetzt mal erzählen.
Also wenn der Termin sieben Minuten ging.
Ihr habt euch ja bestimmt nicht sieben Minuten einfach nur angeguckt.
Was wollte der so wissen?
Bist du eigentlich Wim-Champ?
Ich bin Wim-Champ, ja.
Allerdings ich bin, zur Zeit bin ich eine Mischung aus Wim-Champ, VS Code-Champ und Jetbrains-Champ.
Hauptsächlich VS Code-Champ.
Allerdings auf CLI und über SSH selbstverständlich immer Wim-Champ.
Wie ist Code-Wim-Plugin installiert?
Ne, mag ich nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr merkwürdig.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ich benutze es ganz gerne, wenn es um Kommando-Zeilen-Editing geht.
Kommando-Zeilen-Editing.
Auch geiler Satz.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wenn es ums Bearbeiten von Text-Files auf der Kommando-Zeile geht.
Da wisst ihr ja, ich bin eigentlich hauptsächlich Wim-User.
Aber.
Was ich eigentlich ganz lustig finde, ja.
Also hier, Kommando-Zeile immer automatisch Wim-editieren, alles gut.
Aber wenn ich Visual Studio Code benutze, da habe ich kein Wim-Plugin.
Ich mag das nicht.
Ich kann euch nicht genau erklären, woran das liegt.
Ich weiß halt nur, also mein Gedanke dahinter ist, Wim-VS-Code-Plugins.
Ne, ich mag das nicht.
Ich mag das nicht, weil irgendwie habe ich so mental, schalte ich um zwischen Editor
und Terminal.
Und wenn ich in meinem Hirn im Terminal-Modus bin, dann habe ich auch gar kein Problem mit
Wim-Shortcuts und irgendwie Wim-Abkürzungen, wenn ich in Visual Studio Code bin, dann will
ich Maus klicken können und Multicursor und so ein G'schiss machen können.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt?
Fuck.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich mag kein Wim-Plugin.
Ich habe auch, ich habe auch in Rider kein Wim-Plugin.
Ich habe eigentlich nirgendswo ein Wim-Plugin, außer in Wim.
Ich hatte, wobei das stimmt nicht.
In Emacs, so in Zeiten, als ich noch Emacs verwendet habe, da hatte ich Evil-Mode.
Hat das schon mal jemand verwendet von euch?
Oh, hier gibt's Updates.
Und schon mal Evil-Mode benutzt von euch in Emacs, das ist quasi eine Wim-Emulation für
Emacs.
Böse Zungen behaupten, das ist endlich ein gescheiter Editor für Emacs.
Das heißt Evil-Mode, weil Wim- und Emacs-User sich ja immer ein bisschen gegenseitig bashen
haben.
Also ich glaube, dass alles hundertprozentig wieder weg wäre, müsste ich wahrscheinlich
mal so drei, vier Tage Pause machen, aber nee, das passt schon.
Ich habe mir jetzt ja neue Schuhe gekauft, habe ich euch ja gezeigt.
Ich habe mir jetzt, ich habe mir jetzt ja hier einen Pack, was ist denn Pack?
Ein Paar, kein Pack, Alter.
Ah, Flashbang, Alter.
Ich muss die Seite mal aufmachen in Chrome.
Ich habe mir hier so einen Pack gekauft in Exact.
Wait a minute.
Ich bringe.
Okay.
Okay, ich bringe.
Nee, das hier in dieser, in dieser Farbkombination, weil die haben halt super, super nice Federung
und das ist für Leute wie mich, die jetzt nicht so leicht sind und nicht so dünn sind,
ist das sehr praktisch.
Und ich muss sagen, damit ist viel, ohne Scheiß viel, extrem viel angenehmer zu laufen, als
mit den normalen Turnschuhen.
Das ist RGB.
Das ist RGB, das macht es nochmal extra schneller.
Die Waage, die Waage hat sich bis jetzt nicht verändert.
Ist immer noch, ist immer noch morgens, ja es schwankt, es schwankt zwischen, sag ich mal, 91 und 94, je nachdem.
Also wenn ich mich nicht bewegt habe den Tag, mega viel gefressen habe und mich mit Hose und allem auf die Waage stelle, dann ist es 94.
Und wenn ich mich morgens wiege, dann ist es meistens 92,5 und wenn ich mich wiege, nachdem ich eine Runde gerannt bin, vormittags, dann ist es meistens 91,5 oder so.
Aber es ist, es ist ja, es ist nicht mehr runtergegangen, es ist nicht mehr runtergegangen, seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Bei welcher Größe? 1,74.
Und, also es ist nicht, es ist nicht weiter runtergegangen, seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, woran das liegt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, das dauert einfach ein bisschen.
Ich meine, ich mache ja, ich mache ja eh meine normale Runde am Tag, meine eineinhalb Stunden Wanderrunde und dann halt noch 45 bis 60 Minuten Rennen.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das, ich hatte letztens, zumindest, ich habe ja so eine Fitness-Tracker-Uhr, ich habe letztens übertauert, sagt meine Fitness-Tracker-Uhr, ja,
mit meiner eineinhalb Runde morgens und mit meiner, ähm,
50, paar, 50 Minuten Rennrunde abends,
habe ich über 1000 Kalorien angeblich verbrannt.
Also ich habe quasi ein Drittel, fast ein bisschen mehr als ein Drittel von meinem Tagesbedarf weggerannt.
Ja, also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das erstens so ein bisschen dauert, bis man davon abnimmt.
Und wahrscheinlich werde ich auch erstmal noch ein paar Muskeln jetzt kriegen, dadurch, dass ich damit angefangen habe.
Und, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich am Anfang ein bisschen, ein bisschen verbrannt ist in Muskelmasse.
Und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und.
Na ja, unterm, was heißt jetzt nicht, zum Abnehmen?
Unterm Strich musst du mehr verbrauchen, als du reinschiebst.
Und, wenn du insgesamt am Tag durch Bewegung 1000 Kalorien mehr verbrauchst, dann hast du die am Ende des Tages weniger.
Du suchst nach einem 1,74 Meter großen Dude mit bunten Schuhen, korrekt.
Allerdings nur, wenn ich am Laufen bin.
Wenn ich in der Stadt bin oder so, dann habe ich nicht die Schuhe an.
Zumindest, den finde ich, den finde ich echt nice.
Also, es fühlt sich so viel angenehmer an, damit zu laufen, als mit den normalen Turnschuhen.
Gerade, weil ich dann auch ein bisschen schwerer bin.
Und da knallt halt echt einiges so auf Knie und Schienbein und so drauf.
Und das ein bisschen abfedert.
Und das federt richtig, Leute.
Also, wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt, ich habe auch erst mal gedacht, darauf kann man doch nicht laufen.
Ihr müsst euch das mal bei YouTube angucken, wie das, warte mal, wenn da einer drin läuft,
wie das, das sieht aus wie, weiß nicht, ob der zeigt, wie das läuft.
Das sieht aus, ja hier, er zeigt das drauf schon.
Das sieht aus wie, ja stell dich mal drauf, Kollege.
Äh, man sieht es jetzt hier nicht.
Ähm, das sieht aus, hier, hier.
Guck mal.
Das sieht, das sieht, guck mal, das sieht aus, seht ihr das?
Das, ja man erkennt es, ja doch, hier erkennt man es.
Das ist, das sieht aus, als würde man auf dem.
Kissen laufen, seht ihr das?
Das ist wie, als hätte einer so ein Kissen drunter gepackt.
Aber, es ist extrem, extrem angenehm, da drin zu laufen, wirklich extrem angenehm.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, ich, ich, ich, ich dachte am Anfang so, ja okay, Dämpfung und so, alles ganz nice.
Aber halt sehr wobbel, wobbel alles.
Und ja ist es, aber es ist nicht so schlimm, wie ich gedacht habe.
Dafür ist es halt viel angenehmer.
Dein linker Arm ist überlastet.
Das ist vielleicht auch mal ein Tag Pause, man.
Das ist, das ist Arch, Arch unter den.
Unter den Schuhen, naja.
Das ist aber wirklich ziemlich zackig.
Bin bestimmt nicht der Erste, der das hier schreibt, aber am Freitag geht es los.
Ja, Chatge, bei wem geht es noch freitags los?
Erster Neunter.
Das ist beliebter Startpunkt für Ausbildung und neue Jobs.
Hauptsächlich für Ausbildung.
Bei manchen fängt es, glaube ich, auch schon im August an, bei manchen auch erst im Oktober.
Bei wem geht es noch los?
Oder ist iChankaNotChunk der Einzige?
Einer bester Schei-
Bei dir geht es los in einem Startup.
Starfield, nein.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, es geht um, um, äh, Physi-Start oder sowas.
Oder? Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ich vermute es jetzt einfach mal.
Du bist, du bist Brainlag-Champ.
Das muss ich auch sagen, hier Leute, das hätte ich, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, aber, ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, mein Hirn ist nicht mehr so krass boomer-mäßig.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, mein Hirn ist nicht mehr so krass boomer-mäßig.
Ich habe natürlich das Gefühl, mein Hirn ist nicht mehr so krass boomer...
Seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Mich kommt das vor, als kann ich mich besser konzentrieren.
Aber gut, durch Blutungen und alles.
Aber gut, bei halt Durchblutungen und alles.
Dafür, was anderes,
dafür, ich bin jetzt ziemlich genau 5 Monate bei der neuen, beim neuen Job
und ich war eigentlich bis jetzt durchgehend motiviert.
Aber früher oder später musste das, musste das ja auch mal kommen.
Und jetzt so in den letzten ein, zwei Tagen habe ich es gemerkt, so meine Hyper-Motivation so zum Einstieg hat jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Ich mache zum Glück mittlerweile den größten Teil des Tages, kann ich Zeug machen, worauf ich Bock habe.
Aber so dieses super, ich muss mich überall einbringen, ich muss überall was zu sagen, ich will einen guten Eindruck machen, ich will zeigen, dass ich Ahnung habe und so.
Es verfliegt langsam.
Ich habe jetzt, ich bin zum Beispiel, bin ich jetzt schon wieder in meinem normalen Meeting-Modus angekommen.
Mein normaler Meeting-Modus ist, wenn keiner was sagt zu mir, sage ich auch nichts.
Das ist mein normaler Meeting-Modus, den habe ich seit Jahren schon und ich mache lieber in der Zwischenzeit irgendwas anderes, zum Beispiel irgendwas weiter skripten, irgendwas weiter programmieren, irgendwas weiter ausprobieren.
Und wenn mich halt einer was fragt in Meetings, dann sage ich das.
Bei Dailies überlege ich mir vorher kurz was und sage dann halt ein paar.
Aber meistens sage ich, ja gut, sonst gibt es auch nichts interessantes mehr.
Ich habe so diesen, diesen, diesen, ja, ich, diesen, diesen, wie nennt man das, diesen Bestätigungstrang ist schon wieder weg nach fünf Monaten.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das hält jedes Mal kürzer.
Als ich damals die Ausbildung angefangen habe, Leute, ich hatte das ja gefühlt irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre oder so, wo ich da auf 180 war und immer überall was mitbekommen wollte und sagen wollte und zeigen wollte, dass ich auch jetzt was gelernt habe und so.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es einfach so, wenn man selbst ein bisschen realisiert hat, dass man nicht ganz kacke ist in seinem Bereich, ja, dann, dann lässt so dieser Geltungsdrang einfach auch relativ schnell nach.
Weil man, man muss sich halt nicht unbedingt permanent den ganzen Tag selbst bestätigen mehr.
Am Anfang, ja, so die ersten zwei, drei Monate, sicherlich muss man halt auch mal ein bisschen unter Beweis stellen, dass man schon einen Plan hat.
Das ist auch bestimmt nicht verkehrt, am Anfang das mal zu zeigen.
Aber mittlerweile, ich bin, ich habe es gemerkt, ich habe es heute Morgen.
Richtig gemerkt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, oh, nee, schon wieder Gemiete heute den ganzen Tag und, ach, weißt du was, setz dich in die Meetings, hörst ein bisschen zunehmend bei und bastelst an deinem Kram weiter.
Und wenn mich keiner fragt, sage ich nichts.
Ja, Mann, machst du den, machst du dann den, den Bouldering-Kreisel-Crime.
Ich habe mal ein paar Videos geguckt von, von, von irgendeinem Kerl auf, auf YouTube.
Der ist, das war, das war echt auch super, super krass, als ich das gesehen habe.
Der ist an irgendeinem Felsen auf, frag mich nicht, Teneriffa.
Oder Lanzarote oder so.
Ist der, der ist an so einer Felswand lang geklettert, in so eine Höhle rein.
Und da war nix an dieser Felswand, nix.
Das ist so, da, da hätte ich mich nicht mal, wenn es um Leben und Tod geht, irgendwie dran festhalten können für ein paar Sekunden.
Da war nichts.
Da kommt, die, die Felswand sah für mich einfach glatt aus.
Und der Typ ist da lang geklettert und dann ist der irgendwie so kopfüber in diese Höhle reingeklettert.
Ich meinte, Alter, was geht mir den Leuten ab?
Vor allem, wie hält der sich da fest?
Und dann habe ich von dem gleichen Kerl mal irgendwann so ein Video gesehen in so einem, wie nennt man das, in so einem Kletterstudio?
Wie heißt denn das in so einem Trainingskletterraum?
Ey, Alter, der hat sich an Vorsprüngen festgehalten.
Mit seinen Fingern.
Die hätte ich nicht mal als Vorsprünge erkannt.
Ne, den meine ich nicht, aber von dem habe ich auch schon irgendein, irgend so ein Bergklettervideo geguckt.
Okay.
Ja, was zum Teufel ist mit dem los, ne?
Ne, du, danke für den Sub.
Ähm, was war die Frage? Wo es die Hintergründe gibt? Ja, die Hintergründe gibt es hier. Die hat der Rackman gebastelt.
Ja.
Credits. Hier gibt es die Hintergründe. Guck auf, auf Shithub.
Du hast für jeden Tag,
äh, für jede Tageszeit,
hast du was passendes dabei.
Ja, genau. Noah Laws Pancakes, das war der. Der Name ist mir im Kopf geblieben, ja.
Normalerweise bin ich nicht so ein Sportvideos-Gucker, aber von dem, was ich gerade gesehen habe, habe ich schon ein paar.
Sportvideos-Gucker, aber von dem habe ich mal zwei, drei geguckt. Das, da habe ich auch echt gedacht, das ist nicht normal, woran der Kerl sich festhält.
Äh, falls du Linux benutzt, wer, wer hat das gefragt?
Turtonk?
Ach so, direkt da oben drüber, hatte man ja die Frage.
Ähm, falls du Linux benutzt, kannst du auch eins von diesen beiden Skripts verwenden, um dir automatisch den Background alle
15 Minuten
umzusetzen. In der Variante von Max ist das sogar mit Wetter-API und
anhand der, äh,
Sonnenuntergangszeit setzt du dann sogar in den richtigen Background. Aber du kannst doch einfach
Background...
Was, was hat Ryder am Start hier? Was ist da los?
Wollte ich nicht upgraden gerade? Habe ich nicht gesagt, es soll upgraden?
Und jetzt hier upgraden?
Nothing to do. Verdächtig, verdächtig. Cannot update?
Cannot update? Failed? Moment, Moment. Ist meine Disk voll?
Temp ist...
What the fuck?
Was des?
Was, was liegt denn hier alles für ein Schrott rum in Temp, alter?
What the...
Ich bin ein wenig verwirrt. Ich glaube, ich reboote mal.
Jetzt nach Kernel-Update und sowas.
Keine Ahnung, was das gerade für Schmerzen... Temp ist voll, aber sollte... Ja gut, der anzipft wahrscheinlich in Temp.
War jetzt eigentlich nicht mein Plan, aber schauen wir mal, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Okay, White-Pepo-Happy-Background wurde jetzt gesetzt zu Pepo-Sleep-Time.
Use, 1%. Okay, alles wieder gut.
Lass uns mal schauen. Moment, kann das sein, dass mein Temp zu klein ist, dass ich alle Jetbrain-Tools auf einmal updaten kann?
Vor allem, warum habe ich bitte schon IntelliJ installiert? Ich mache doch gar kein Java-Zeug.
Lass mal kurz zugucken hier. Watch.df-h.
Ja, ja.
Alter, der lädt nach Temp runter. Ist das total bescheuert?
Was ist das für Pepega-Shit, alter?
Was ist das für Pepega-Shit?
Kann er das nicht in Home machen? Da hat er 133 Gig frei.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir brauchen IntelliJ eh nicht.
Uninstall. Oh, easy.
Oh, thanks.
Jetzt Update. Das hatte ich aber auch noch nicht.
Moment, guck mal, der gibt das gar nicht wieder frei.
Das ist ja richtig krasses Pepega-Zeug.
Gibt der das wieder frei, wenn ich das hier...
Warum gibt der es dann beim Rebooten frei?
Löscht der neuerdings Temp beim Rebooten? Das ist aber auch nicht normal.
Daku, dankeschön für den Sub.
So, jetzt. Jetzt probieren wir das noch einmal.
Vielleicht hätte ich es beenden sollen.
Ja, jetzt ist es wieder frei. So.
Okay.
Toolbox.
Gucken, ob das jetzt geht.
Also, ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man es einzeln updatet, wird es ohne Probleme funktionieren.
Das ist doch aber auch neu.
Nee, dass es nach TMP geht, oder?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Das benutzt er wirklich nur für den Download.
Guck mal.
Das braucht er nur für den Download.
Der Rest ist kein Ding.
Funktioniert.
Easy.
Ist auch Schrott, oder?
Na gut.
So, gut. Haben wir geupdatet.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum ich überhaupt gestartet und geupdatet habe, aber...
Okay.
IntelliJ war es für der Java.
Ja.
Java-Kram, wie immer.
Wieso sollte man sich Vim auch in VS Code antun?
Naja, wenn man Vim-Fan ist und die Vim-Shortcuts und die Vim...
Das sind ja keine Shortcuts in Vim. Wie kann man das nennen?
Die, die, die Vim...
Diese Vim-Language zum Texteditieren gerne benutzt. Warum nicht?
Also, ich kenne einige, die das machen. Nicht nur in VS Code.
Motions, genau.
Sondern auch in allen möglichen anderen IDE. Es gibt ja für fast alle Vim-Plugins.
Wobei, so richtig gut ist es eigentlich nur in Vim.
Oder? Oder meins?
Wegen den Emacs, falls irgendjemand so verrückt noch ist.
Aber ich mag das nicht. Ich mag es in Vim selber.
Aber ich mag es nicht in anderen Editors.
Ich zeige euch übrigens mal was.
Ist TempFS für FS nicht im RAM?
Nee.
Moment.
Ist es TempFS?
Sekunde.
Doch, dann ist es im...
Nee, Quatsch.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss mal gucken.
TempFS schon, aber...
Aber Temp nicht unbedingt.
Moment, ist es im RAM?
Moment, habe ich das im RAM?
Ich glaube, das ist im RAM.
Das ist gar nicht auf meiner Disk.
Ach, deswegen ist es nur...
Ist es...
RAM-Disk.
Ach, so.
Deswegen habe ich auch nur 12 GB Temp, weil das in RAM geht.
Okay.
Wie viel habe ich denn an RAM drinne?
Ja, 24 GB.
Ja, deswegen erklärt.
Aber das sollte trotzdem nicht sein.
Was er so viel da braucht.
Ich wollte euch noch...
Den 5-Head-Win-Hack zeigen.
Passt mal auf.
Config.
Westerm.
Lua.
So, jetzt machen wir hier irgendwas auf.
So, Chat.
Mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt diesen String hier austauschen.
Primary Selection.
Von der Stelle hier.
Was ist die beste Variante, das zu machen?
Wer ist der...
Wer ist der Wim-5-Header hier?
Ja?
Das ist gut?
CI?
Ja.
Okay, ich sehe Chat.
Ihr kennt das schon alle.
Also, einige kennt es, ja.
Du kannst...
Du kannst CI, CI, Change, Inner und dann Quotes.
Und dann springt er zum nächsten Zeichen und dazwischen löchert er das dann.
Das geht auch mit Wörtern hier.
CIW zum Beispiel.
Wobei man das mit CW in dem Fall einfacher haben kann.
Ja, also das kann man sich merken.
Das ist tatsächlich eines der nützlichsten Wim-Dinger, weil man will ja oftmals Variablen neu anlegen.
Das funktioniert übrigens mit ganz viel.
Das funktioniert auch mit...
Mit Single Quotes.
Change, Inner.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt die Tasse...
Ja.
Geht das...
Das geht auch mit...
Klammern.
Das geht eigentlich mit fast allem.
Ja, ja, das geht auch.
Wobei ich glaube...
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass der Multiline-fähig ist.
Oh, guck mal, der kann sogar Multiline.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Change, Inner, Klammern.
Hä?
Multiline-5-Head.
Ja, es gibt noch mehr.
Aber das wollte ich euch an der Stelle bloß mal zeigen.
Weil ich das immer ganz, ganz praktisch finde.
Okay.
Naja, das war jetzt nicht so viel, was wir dich gefragt haben.
Ja, und was hast du für einen Eindruck von denen?
Ich meine, in der heutigen Zeit ist es ja so, dass es nicht unbedingt primär nur darauf ankommt, dass die wollen, sondern dass du auch willst.
Also, ich hatte heute einen Termin mit meinem Chef und der hat gemeint, sie wollen mich auch nach der Probezeit behalten.
Aber das...
Ich meine, das war vor...
Wenn nicht, wäre vorher ja schon klar gewesen.
Das hat er, glaube ich, nur so als Gag eingestreut.
Übrigens, ach, Max, wir wollen dich auch nach der Probezeit behalten.
Weil es ist ja...
Ich meine, in einem Monat ist meine Probezeit rum.
Ja, und so wie es aussieht, die Kollegen auch.
Wie setzt du Wim auf für Softwareentwicklung?
Gar nicht.
Ich entwickle in Wim nichts Großartiges.
Ich editiere nur auf der Kommandozeile und über SSH überschaubare Sachen.
Downfix oder irgendwelche Skripts oder wenn mal was angepasst werden muss nachträglich, was schon auf dem Server liegt oder so.
Ich mache keine großen Projekte mit Wim.
Da drehe ich durch bei.
Ich habe das früher gemacht.
Ich hatte früher mal ein Wim aufgemotzt wie sonst was.
Ja, C Sharp in Wim willst du nicht machen.
Wobei das mit Language, Server und sowas alles irgendwo möglich ist.
Aber es ist immer noch kacke.
Weil einiges von diesem ganzen C Sharp Tooling ist halt nicht...
Ich will nicht sagen, nicht Open Source.
Das ist es nicht.
Aber nicht...
War wahrscheinlich auch nicht Open Source.
Aber auf jeden Fall nicht gut integrierbar.
Das siehst du ja bei Jetprince Rider.
Die haben ja vieles selbst gebaut und benutzen gar nicht das Microsoft Zeug.
Ja, und dementsprechend ist...
Dementsprechend ist die Sharp in Visual Studio Code witzigerweise auch totaler Müll.
Nee, die Schuhe kosten nicht 200 Euro.
Das habe ich letztens schon gezeigt.
Wenn man bei Amazon guckt...
Hier, da hatte ich da letztens schon gesucht.
Guck mal.
Bei Amazon kosten die 135 Euro.
Oder guck mal hier, 124 Euro.
Zwischen 100, 24, 140.
Also warum auch immer die 200 kosten auf der offiziellen Seite.
Keine Ahnung.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Da ist man ein bisschen hin.
Wobei, du bist eine Ecke größer.
Vielleicht, ja.
3000 Kalorien am...
Ja, klar.
Ich meine, du verbrauchst...
Du verbrauchst durch pures Existieren schon ordentlich was an Kalorien.
Wichtig ist halt dadurch...
Es ist jetzt gar nicht so, dass man bei den meisten Sachen...
Es sei denn, du...
Du machst halt wirklich mehrere Stunden am Tag Sport.
Dass du da so wahnsinnig viel krasses...
Riesenmengen dadurch verbrauchst.
Aber es ist einfach ein bisschen mehr als das, was du wieder reinschaufelst dadurch.
Und ansonsten schaufelst du vielleicht ein bisschen mehr rein als das, was du verbrauchst.
Mit Abstand.
Es sei denn, du fährst eine Tour de France Etappe oder sowas.
Der größte Teil ist einfach pures Existieren, was du brauchst.
Am Tag.
Ja, natürlich kommt es aufs Gewicht und sowas an.
Max holt sich bald sowas.
Kann ich das anklicken hier im Stream?
Ich meine, es kommt von Modgids.
Dann hoffe ich mal, dass da...
So was.
Das habe ich mir auch schon angeguckt.
Das hat mir persönlich nicht so zugesagt.
Ich habe Socken.
Ich habe so Socken für einzelne Zehen.
Ich habe so Socken mittlerweile.
Aber...
Ich glaube, Schuhe eher nicht.
Nee, also...
Wenn du, wenn du, sagen wir mal, im Durchschnitt 93 Kilo wiegst, wie ich,
und beim Rennen immer, immer auf die...
Ich meine, das geht halt sehr aufs Bein.
Das geht auf die...
Ich merke es ja auch so schon mit gepolstertem Schuh.
Auf die Knie und aufs Schienbein.
Also es ist deutlich angenehmer, wenn du was gepolstertes drunter hast.
Haben deine Zehen viel Spielraum?
Nee.
Eigentlich nicht.
Aber es ist auch nicht so, als würde es irgendwie...
Irgendwo kratzen oder so.
Die passen eigentlich...
Also ich habe 44,5 Größe von denen.
Das geht eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Erste Arbeitstag am Freitag.
Pogge.
Kannst du sagen, ich bin Mordgeber bei Wubblos.
Pfeifert.
Gleich mehr Geld.
Only Pfeifert.
Nur Pfeiferter sollen mit mir reden hier.
Alles, alles, alles ohne Chat-EQ war ich nicht.
Hast du noch irgendwelche Tipps, um die erste Woche gut zu überstehen?
Tja.
Eigentlich müsste ich gute Tipps haben, weil bei mir ist die erste Woche...
...im neuen Job ja selbst noch nicht lange her.
Also ganz ehrlich, guck, dass du alle Zugänge, Hardware und so dir organisierst.
Du wirst eh komplett überfordert sein, was Abkürzungen und eigene Sprechweise angeht.
Also wenn ich eine Sache gemerkt habe.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich jedes Jahr den Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Aber ein paar Mal ist es jetzt schon der Fall gewesen.
Und zum letzten Mal eben am 1. April.
Wenn mir eine Sache aufgefallen ist.
Jedes Unternehmen hat so einen leicht anderen Slang.
Auch wenn...
Ich nenne es halt einfach mal so.
So ein leicht anderes Enterprise-Speak.
Also sprich, auch wenn man überall vielleicht ähnliche Aufgabenbereiche hat.
Ja, irgendwie IT, Linux, sonst was in der Richtung.
Es reden trotzdem alle anders.
Es haben alle andere Abkürzungen.
Es bezeichnen viele gleiche Dinge anders.
Zum Beispiel.
Eine...
Äh...
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Ja, genau.
Im alten Unternehmen, wo ich war.
Da gab es für Störungen und für Services, gab es verschiedene Klassifizierungen.
Da gab es dann zum Beispiel so etwas wie eine Stufe 1 Störung.
Das bedeutete, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Service.
Und es sind da auch quasi viele oder besonders wichtige Kunden betroffen.
Das war dann Stufe 1 Störung.
Im Unternehmen, wo ich jetzt bin, ist es eine, nicht Stufe 1, sondern das ist das höchste, eine Klasse 3.
Das sind so Dinge, wo man sich denkt, okay, jeder labert irgendwas anderes, aber meinen eigentlich alle das Gleiche.
Da muss man sich erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Und es gibt überall etwas anderen Slang und Business-Speak, so Enterprise-Speak.
Das macht jedes Unternehmen ein bisschen anders.
Zumindest...
Zumindest eine Sache, was alle Unternehmen gemein haben, ist, und das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch merken, wenn du neu anfängst.
Alle feiern sich.
Alle Unternehmen feiern sich übelst.
Das muss einem ein bisschen ins eine Ohr...
Also man darf sich dadurch nicht zu sehr beeindrucken lassen.
Das muss einem ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen...
Ich weiß nicht, Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Aus meiner Meinung...
Meine Meinung ist dazu, das können die ja alle machen in einem gewissen Rahmen.
Aber es muss einem schon ein bisschen ins eine Ohr reingehen und ins andere rausgehen.
Weil ich...
Ich kann mich einfach nicht genug damit identifizieren, dass ich die gleichen Sachen abfeiere, wie das, was irgendjemand da erzählt.
Ich krieg das...
Ich...
Ich verstehe oftmals, was sie sagen wollen und viele der Aussagen dahinter sind auch gar nicht schlecht.
Aber du weißt halt eh, es werden immer nur die besten Sachen rausgepickt und erzählt.
Und letztendlich denken...
Tun alle Unternehmen so, als tun sie der Menschheit was Gutes.
In Wirklichkeit geht's...
Um Kohle machen und so.
Das ist doch allen klar.
Ich find das immer ein bisschen...
Bisschen blöd, wenn da so...
Sich so ultra krass selbst gehuldigt wird.
Das geht mir bei Stellenanzeigen schon immer auf den Keks.
Also, meiner Meinung nach...
Es macht keinen Sinn, irgendwie dann...
Dann irgendwie zu nerven und blöde Fragen zu stellen oder so.
Weil die stehen ja da oftmals auch viele Leute dahinter und so.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere Ohr raus, wenn da wieder die Selbsthuldigungsgeschichte kommt.
Triton, moin, dankeschön für den Sub.
Bock, sechs Monate.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Ja, aber gut.
Und wenn's mal auf die Sache zurückkommt...
Guck, dass du da...
Moment, du fängst als Azubi an, ne?
Ja gut, da auch, ne?
Also, guck, dass sie dir Zugänge und Hardware besorgen.
Dass du überhaupt die Möglichkeit...
Die erste Woche reicht's, wenn du dafür sorgst, dass du irgendwie überhaupt in der Lage bist zu arbeiten.
Dass du weißt, wo du sitzt.
Dass du dir das Gebäude anguckst.
Dass du weißt, wo was Wichtiges ist.
Wann hat die Kantine auf?
Wichtige Sachen zuerst, logisch.
Aber...
Normalerweise...
Wann macht die Kantine auf?
Wann macht die Kantine zu?
Wann macht irgendein Kiosk auf?
Wann macht irgendein Kiosk zu?
Getränkeautomat, wo ist das Ganze?
In welchem Stock, in welche Ecke setze ich?
Glaub mir, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Wenn du...
Wenn es ein größerer Laden ist, du wirst dich erstmal ein bisschen verlaufen.
Das heißt, merk dir die Raumnummer, merk dir das Stockwerk, merk dir den Fahrstuhl, wo die Fahrstühle sind.
Und was dein Büro ist und so ein paar Sachen, wo man wie wohin kommt.
Und vielleicht, was für die erste Woche noch ganz gut ist, wenn man versucht, so rauszuhören, was so die Dinger sind, die man vielleicht besser nicht machen sollte.
Jedes Unternehmen hat da immer so ein bisschen andere Sachen.
Ich meine, klar, es gibt die offensichtlichsten Sachen, die jeder weiß.
Du solltest nichts klauen, da wirst du instant rausgeschmissen.
Aber das meine ich nicht.
Es gibt in manchen Unternehmen eben so ungeschriebene Regeln, die beim anderen vollkommen okay sind, ja.
Zum Beispiel...
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, ja.
Bei dem einen Unternehmen ist es vollkommen okay, wenn du aus einem Meeting rausgehst, wenn es laut Kalender fertig ist.
Obwohl die Leute noch am diskutieren sind.
Ohne, dass du was sagst.
Du haust einfach ab.
Vollkommen okay.
In einem anderen Unternehmen wirst du vielleicht doof angeguckt, warum du einfach abhaust.
Und in einem wieder anderen Unternehmen, wenn du sagst, oh, ich muss jetzt weg.
Ich habe noch ein anderes Parallel-Meeting, einen anderen Termin.
Dann sagen sie, ja, dann geh doch einfach und spam nicht im Chat rum.
Also, das ist überall ein bisschen anders.
Und eventuell auch von Gruppe zu Gruppe und Team zu Team alles ein bisschen anders.
Also, es gibt überall Dinger, da macht man sich ein bisschen unbeliebt mit.
Und wenn man da so die erste Woche mal drauf achtet, man merkt das ja auch bei den anderen, ja.
Also ein bisschen drauf achten ist nicht verkehrt, dann macht man selber halt das nicht.
Und wenn du...
Wenn du beispielsweise einen Ausbildungsleiter hast, der eben sehr scharf drauf ist,
dass du freitags deinen Ausbildungsbericht vorlegst,
ja, dann guck halt, dass du dem bis freitags den Ausbildungsbericht vorlegst.
Bei mir war es so, bei mir haben sie sich drei Jahre nicht für die Ausbildungsberichte interessiert
und dementsprechend, naja.
Chat, was meint ihr, wie viele Ausbildungsberichte hatte ich geschrieben bis zum dritten Jahr?
Oder bis kurz vor meiner Abschlussprüfung?
Drei, null.
Nee, es waren weder drei noch null.
Ich denke mal...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es waren.
Ich denke mal so 15 oder so 10, 15, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Weil ich habe die ersten paar Wochen das noch relativ gewissenhaft gemacht
und dann hat halt meine Faulheit overtaked.
Und dann habe ich ab und zu mal wieder welche gemacht.
Und irgendwann habe ich einfach...
So nach dem ersten halben Jahr habe ich einfach gar keine mehr gemacht.
Und dann musste ich quasi zu meiner Abschlussprüfung zusammen faken.
Und dann habe ich dann drei Jahre Abschluss...
Drei Jahre...
Drei Jahre Ausbildungsnachweise-Berichte.
Ich habe da was gebastelt, was automatisch das zusammen bestückelt.
Und die waren richtig schlecht.
Also ohne Scheiß.
Meine Ausbildungsberichte waren die schlechtsten.
Ich glaube, schlechte Ausbildungsberichte kannst du nicht haben.
Teilweise ganze Tage gar nichts, was da drin stand.
Dann hatte ich so 20, 25 Sachen, die sich immer wiederholt haben.
Und so richtig mies alles.
Das liest sich eh keiner durch.
Verlass dich mal nicht drauf.
Wie gesagt.
Vielleicht hast du einen Ausbildungsbetreuer, der da voll drauf steht.
Und das gerne sich jeden Freitag anguckt, jeden Montag sich vorstellt.
Guck, benutze die erste Woche, um so ein bisschen Gefühl für den Laden zu kriegen.
Das ist, glaube ich, der beste Tipp, den man einem geben kann.
Und versuch, sagen wir mal so, versuchen möglichst netten und guten Eindruck zu machen.
Erster Eindruck ist entscheidend.
Dein Chef und wer auch immer sonst wie Vorstellungsgespräche mit dir hatte, der kennt dich ja zumindest.
Der hat dich schon mal gesehen.
Aber viele Leute triffst du da zum ersten Mal.
Und wenn du gleich anfängst mit den blöden Sprüchen, was manche machen, was bei uns in dem alten Unternehmen, wo wir auch ab und zu ein paar Azubis gekümmert haben, hatten wir wirklich welche.
Die haben halt dann schon in der ersten Woche irgendwelche coolen Sprüche gebracht.
Das haben die nicht gemacht, weil sie gedacht haben, das wäre ein sonderlich schlauer Spruch.
Die wollten halt irgendeinen coolen Spruch machen, weil sie nicht besser wussten, was sie sagen sollten.
Ja, also da sollte man vielleicht die erste.
Woche ein bisschen, ein bisschen am Riemen reißen, wenn man die Leute dann kennen.
Und wenn man die Leute kennt und weiß, wer wie tickt, da kann man das machen.
Der erste Woche ist, glaube ich, echt das Beste, was man machen kann.
Bisschen das Gefühl, Gefühl für den Laden kriegen, wie da die Dinger laufen und wieso die Leute ticken.
Aber jetzt vorbei.
Ne, hast du nicht geschrieben?
Erster, neunter oder so.
Freitag geht's los.
Prog.
Hi IQ Proggers.
Geht das überhaupt als IT-Mensch, fünf Monate arbeitslos zu sein, wenn man was sucht?
Du wirst doch, du hättest ja einfach ein LinkedIn-Profil machen müssen.
Da wirst du wahrscheinlich überschwemmt.
Okay, überschwemmt mit Shit zum größten Teil.
Ich habe das Gefühl, man bewirbt nichts in deutschen Unternehmen.
Wird viel drüber geredet, dass wir mal was anderes machen müssen, aber niemand geht.
Das liegt aber auch an dem Laden, je nachdem, wo man ist.
Also, je, je, also ich will das nicht ganz verallgemeinern.
Es mag vielleicht welche geben, da ist das anders.
Aber in der Regel kann man sagen, je größer, umso weniger flexibel und umso weniger änderungswillig sind die Unternehmen und umso weniger Einfluss hat man da auch als Einzelner drauf.
Das sieht man zum Beispiel daran, dass sich da dort oftmals für mega viel, ganz viel teures Geld irgendwelche Berater geholt werden.
Die stellen dann irgendwas vor und da wird dann gesagt, oh, ganz tolle Maßnahmen, jetzt geht es an die Umsetzung und von der Umsetzung passiert mir irgendwas.
Das ist dann aber nicht gemacht, weil man sich wirklich ändern möchte oder was besser machen möchte.
Ja, also die Unternehmen wollen gar nichts besser machen.
Die wollen aber verkaufen können, dass sie was besser machen.
Ja, also zum Beispiel der IT-Chef möchte zeigen, ey, guck mal, wir gehen voll mit der Zeit, hat aber gar keinen Bock, was zu ändern.
Also holt er sich ein paar Unternehmensmöglichkeiten.
Also holt er sich ein paar Unternehmensberater rein, die schreiben dann irgendein ganz tolles Konzept und das wird dann präsentiert.
Und schon denkt der Vorstand und der Chef, alles ganz geil, super toll, voll für die Zukunft gerüstet und in Wirklichkeit ändert sich gar nichts.
Das ist eine sehr beliebte Taktik.
Wenn du sowas merkst, ja, uns nicht stört, gibt es meistens keine, also wenn ja, man kann versuchen, da was zu machen, aber du wirst wenig Chancen haben.
Also er hilft, wenn einem das wirklich stört so sehr.
Wenn einem das wirklich auf den Sack geht.
Viele Sachen, da hilft wahrscheinlich echt nur sich was Neues suchen.
Und in der Regel würde ich sagen, umso größer der Laden und umso, nicht nur umso größer, umso größer und gleichzeitig umso mehr das an Behörde dran ist, umso schlimmer ist es.
Also das Schlimmste vom Schlimmsten, was das angeht, müssten wahrscheinlich große Behörden sein.
Gefolgt von großen Banken und großen Versicherungen und sowas in der Richtung.
Immer weiter.
Abstufung.
Dafür hat das auch seine Vorteile, in so einem großen Laden zu arbeiten.
Ich meine zum Beispiel, stell dir mal vor, du bist jetzt 50, willst ordentlich noch Kohle verdienen, hast jetzt aber keinen Bock hier, die super krass reinzuhängen.
Dann fährst du in so einem Laden halt im Zweifelsfall in recht ruhigen Gewässern.
Ja, du bist dann, bist anwesend, machst so halbwegs deinen Job, dir geht keiner auf den Sack, du gehst keinem auf den Sack.
Wenn man sowas sucht, ist das sicherlich dann auch nicht verkehrt.
Gibt ja genug Leute, die haben ja keine Ambitionen, großartig was verändern zu wollen.
Dann ist das nicht verkehrt.
Wenn du jetzt allerdings jemand bist, der wirklich sagt, ey, mir geht das voll auf den Keks und ich will auch mal das, wenn ich was vorschlage, dass das auch wirklich verwirklicht wird.
Oder wenn ich irgendwie da in einem Projekt mitarbeite, dass ich da voll Impact habe auf das, wie es dann im Endeffekt, ja, dann ist vielleicht ein bisschen was kleineres besser geeignet.
Man muss aber auch sagen, das tendenziell tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich umso größer, umso sicherer auf der einen Seite ist der Job, wenn einem das wichtig ist.
Mir persönlich ist es jetzt nicht so ultra wichtig, also mir wären andere Sachen wichtiger.
Wir haben ja mal so eine Liste gemacht, was mir wichtig ist.
Weiß ich aber nicht mehr, wo ich die habe.
Und oftmals ist halt bei so ganz großen Enterprise Dingern, ist auch die Bezahlung ganz brauchbar.
Also tendenziell, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es da statistisch...
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es so ist.
Das müssen wir mal gucken.
Tendenziell wirst du bei größeren auch mehr verdienen, als bei irgendwelchen Startup Klitschen.
Dafür, das ist halt das eine extrem zum anderen.
Bei irgendwelchen kleinen Startup Klitschen kannst du halt super was bewirken.
Weißt halt nicht, ob der Laden morgen noch da ist und ob das nächste Gehalt kommt, übertrieben gesagt.
Und wenn du bei irgend so einem riesengroßen Business Enterprise Ding...
Bist, da ist die Bezahlung ganz gut und morgen ist es auch noch da, aber es wird sich von heute auf morgen nicht viel ändern.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Ne, nur danke für den Sub.
Herr Schrocker, POG-Subscription habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Dankeschön.
Prime-Sub.
Das ist ja sehr, sehr...
Nice.
Ist das eine VM auf dem zweiten Desktop?
Korrekt, das ist eine VM.
Hier, guckt da, Windows, Linux, Linux, Windows und noch, noch verwirrender, Windows, Linux, Windows.
Windows, Linux, Windows.
Linux, Windows?
Windows, Linux, Windows, ja.
Das ist, man sieht es hier auf dem zweiten Desktop, eine VM im Fullscreen, die kannst du dann umschalten mit Control, Windows-Taste, Pfeiltaste rechts, Pfeiltaste links.
Bin nur der macOS Knopf.
Wir hatten uns schon mal eine macOS VM installiert, aber macOS performt in VMs.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Sehr mies.
Im entsprechenden habe ich das nicht mehr.
Ja, mein Chef hat mir heute erzählt, ich hatte heute Rücksprache mit meinem Chef, mein Chef hat mir heute erzählt, ich soll irgend so einen ollen On-Prem, wie die coolen Cloud-Native Leute das ja aussprechen, ja, wir sind uns ja einig, es heißt nicht mehr lokal oder offline oder bei uns im Rechenzentrum, es heißt auch nicht mehr On-Premise, die coolen Cloud-Native Leute, die sagen On-Prem für alles, was im eigenen Rechenzentrum läuft.
Hat mir mein Chef heute erzählt.
Ich soll irgend so einen ollen On-Prem-Service als Verantwortlicher übernehmen.
Habe ich schon, mache ich gar kein Thema.
Es sind auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünf Linux-Kisten oder so, das ist kein Ding, das mache ich.
Solange er mir am Ende sagt, wie viel Zeit, für was, mache ich das alles.
Juckt mich nicht.
Aber ich habe ja auch gleich dazu erzählt, natürlich, ich meine, in der ganzen Stellenanzeige ging es um Cloud-Geschichten, Cloud-Automatisierung, Cloud-Plattformen.
Kubernetes, Terraform, also ich möchte schon hauptsächlich auch das machen.
Aber wenn da die ein oder anderen On-Prem-Linux-Kisten dabei sind, dann juckt mich das auch nicht.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich gemerkt habe.
Man hat die wenigsten Probleme.
Ihr wisst, ihr kennt meine Einstellung, Leute, ich fahre meistens die, was macht am wenigsten Probleme, das mache ich, Einstellung.
Und eine Sache habe ich auch über die Jahre geguckt.
Ich weiß, das ist nicht für jeden was.
Es gibt Leute, die müssen wirklich wegen jedem Furz diskutieren und jedem, worauf er Bock hat, soll er machen.
Es gibt sicherlich auch viele Dinge, wo ich mir denke, das ist nicht so toll.
Und ich sage dann auch oftmals was zu, irgendwie macht es ja keinen Sinn.
Aber wenn sie es dann haben wollen, ist es okay.
Und eine Sache habe ich die Jahre über gemerkt.
Oftmals, wenn irgendwie einer was vorschlägt, so nach dem Motto, oh Max, willst du dich in Zukunft nicht um diesen Service kümmern?
Ja, man könnte das ja auch als Ziel definieren für Gehaltsbonus und sowas.
Anstatt zu diskutieren, zu sagen, oh, eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock auf so alte On-Prem-Linux-Kisten und sonst was.
Teilweise noch Red Hat 6 oder sowas drauf.
Anstatt da zu diskutieren, das Einfachste ist zu sagen, yo, easy, kein Problem, geb alles her.
Und dann erst mal abwarten, was kommt.
Genau, erst mal abwarten, was kommt.
Weil meistens kommt gar nicht so viel davon mehr.
Und oftmals ist es total easy Kram.
Viele Leute neigen dazu, den einfachsten Kram irgendwie, wenn sie einen fragen, ob man sich die Sache annehmen kann.
Das hört sich immer viel mehr an, als es ist.
Beispielsweise hat mich auch jemand gefragt, hier Max, ich bin irgendwie in zwei Monaten im Urlaub.
Wir haben, an irgendeinem Samstag ist das, haben wir Wartungsarbeiten dafür.
Und da gibt es diesen Service.
Und könntest du nicht vielleicht die Wartungsarbeiten machen?
Ich weiß, du bist ja das ganze Jahr über da.
Im Dezember bist du weg, aber das ganze Jahr über bist du da.
Kannst du das nicht machen?
Da hab ich mir auch erst mal gedacht, pff, okay, eigentlich hab ich von diesem Service, den du da betreust, überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Aber ich hab einfach gesagt, easy, kein Problem, mach ich.
Kann ich machen.
Mach ich gerne, zeig her.
Und er hat mir das gezeigt.
Und im Endeffekt krieg ich Geld für 8 Stunden.
Für 8 Stunden, irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 200%, weil Wochenende.
Nochmal oben drauf.
Mit Bereitschaft bis Montag früh.
Ich verdiene dann irgendwie an einem Wochenende durch den Einsatz, keine Ahnung, 1200 Euro oder sowas.
Für diese Samstag plus zwei Tage Bereitschaft.
Und wisst ihr, was ich machen muss am Ende?
Er hat mir das heute gezeigt.
Ich muss drei Shell-Kommandos ausführen.
Das ist kein, ohne Scheiß, Leute, kein Witz.
Ich muss drei Shell-Kommandos ausführen in 8 Stunden.
Ich übertreib jetzt nicht, ich weiß nicht, das hört sich jetzt so, nein, das ist wirklich so, ich muss drei Shell-Kommandos ausführen.
Das soll nicht mit Cron gemacht werden, weil das ein, da machen nicht nur wir Wartungsarbeiten, da sind noch mehr Leute aktiv.
Und das ist so.
Und das ist sowas mit Koordinator und man muss immer die einzelnen Steps an den Koordinator melden.
Und ich hab halt einen Step, im Endeffekt, ich will es euch jetzt nicht zu sehr im Detail erzählen, aber ich hab einen Step morgens, irgendwie 8.30 Uhr oder so ist das, glaube ich.
Hab ich einen Step, Shell-Skript ausführen oder beziehungsweise Shell-Kommando ausführen.
Und mir die Ausgabe kurz anzugucken und die Ergebnisse der Ausgabe.
Auf eine Netzwerk-Share zu sichern.
So.
Dann melde ich den Koordinator, vorbereitende Aufgaben, äh, vorbereitende Maßnahmen sind erledigt.
Dann machen die ihr Zeug.
Wenn die fertig sind mit ihrem Zeug, so irgendwann um 13 Uhr, wisch das gleiche Shell-Kommando nochmal aus, scroll über den Output drüber, sichere das Ergebnis auf eine Netzwerk-Share.
Und dann ratet mal, was ich um 17.30 Uhr mache.
Kommt ihr nie drauf.
Es ist nicht, nicht erratbar, Chat.
Was ich um 17.30 Uhr mache.
Reboot, ne.
Ne.
Ich führe das gleiche Shell-Kommando nochmal aus.
Und sichere den Output auf ein Netzwerk-Laufwerk.
Auf ein Netz-Laufwerk.
Und dann ess ich Nudeln mit Lachs, genau.
So.
Und das war's.
Das ist alles.
Mehr muss ich nicht machen, an dem Tag.
Hat sich viel, hat sich viel gemacht.
Hat sich viel, hat sich viel größer und wichtiger angehört, als es letztendlich ist.
Ne.
Und aus, das, das ist der Grund, warum ich eigentlich pauschal bei solchen Sachen, also natürlich, wenn ich schon weiß, dass es Ultramist ist, dann nicht.
Aber bei solchen Sachen sage ich, yo, easy, kein Problem.
Mach ich, erzähl's mir.
Also, bevor ich ja sage, erzähl's mir mal.
Aber an sich klingt nicht als wär's ein Problem.
Mach ich.
Kein, kein Thema.
Und meistens fährt man damit am besten.
Viele Sachen sind total easy.
Und die Diskussion dauert länger, als sich das mal kurz zeigen zu lassen.
Also, DarkoXTV, danke für den Sub.
Ja, ich muss drei Schellbefehle, drei, drei Schellbefehle ausführen.
Aber wie, wie weit hinten dran bin ich?
Alter, ich bin, fuck man, wo bin ich denn im Chat?
Warum bist du damals von Emacs weg?
Überlege, überlege selbst, mich da einzuarbeiten.
Bin ich von Emacs weg?
Ja, ja, kann ich dir sagen.
Also, Elisp ist Schrott.
Abfuck hoch 10.
Die Customizability ist nice, aber dafür sind viele Defaults Schrott.
Dieses, man kann alles in Emacs machen, ist eigentlich komplett unsinnig.
In der heutigen Zeit.
Weil ordentlich Browsen kannst du nicht in Emacs.
Ordentlich E-Mails lesen kannst du nicht, je nachdem was ist.
In Emacs mehr, nicht mehr.
Und Text editieren kannst du in Emacs.
Aber, da finde ich gibt es einfachere Varianten.
Also, und für Customizability ist Visual Studio Code mittlerweile sogar noch deutlich besser als Emacs.
Einfach weil es Javascript ist und jeder Javascript Plugins machen kann und kaum noch irgendjemand was für Emacs entwickelt.
Die Emacs Userbase ist geschrumpft, extrem geschrumpft die letzten Jahre.
Und auch das Plugin Ökosystem, wo vieles weniger entwickelt wird.
Also insofern, Emacs ist noch nicht mal mehr ein gutes OS.
Und insofern, war das irgendwann nichts mehr.
Nee, Chatbrains schreibt die Datei nach Temp und mein Temp ist im RAM als RAM-Disk gemountet.
Ja, das macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
Deswegen, deswegen verwende ich ja auch WIM nicht als IDE.
Wobei man sagen muss, hey, so pauschal kann man das in der heutigen Zeit gar nicht mehr sagen.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was es ist.
Es kommt wirklich ein bisschen drauf an, was es ist.
Also, ich sage mal, Python und Javascript zum Beispiel kannst du wunderbar in WIM machen.
Weil der Language Server ziemlich gut ist und die Plugins ziemlich gut sind.
Also ich denke, das steht in IDEs in fast nichts nach.
Wenn man eben da drauf steht.
Bei C, C Sharp und Java sieht es sicherlich ganz anders aus.
Kennst du irgendeine Datenbank mit eingebauter Rest-API, sodass man sich das Backend sparen kann?
Ja, Postgres.
Postgres mit...
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Ähm, nee.
Da gab es doch so ein recht bekanntes...
Nee.
Post...
Nee, das...
Das meine ich nicht.
Vielleicht meine ich doch das.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Superbase meine ich nicht.
Es gab doch...
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Es gab doch ein recht großes Projekt.
Postgres.
Und dann glaube ich CraftQL Endpunkt davor.
Meine ich das?
Es könnte sein, dass ich das meine tatsächlich.
Es könnte sein, dass ich das meine.
Also, nimm ne Postgres.
Postgres ist defaultmäßig immer gut.
Postgres und mit einem der Services, wo Postgres mit Rest-Endpunkt macht.
Sowas gibt es übrigens wahrscheinlich auch für viele andere Datenbanken.
Also bestimmt auch für, keine Ahnung, MySQL oder sowas.
Ja, das geht auch.
Wobei es...
Wobei, ganz ehrlich.
Rest-Endpunkt für eine Datenbank ist so ein Ding.
CraftQL macht in dem Fall aus meiner Sicht mehr Sinn.
Weil, ich meine, mach halt mal mit einer Rest-API ein Join oder sowas.
Das ist halt...
Da nicht so dafür gedacht.
CraftQL ist da deutlich sinniger.
Kenne ich.
Mag ich nicht.
Beste...
Beste ist immer noch git command line.
Wobei das Plugin doch ganz cool ist.
Das zeigt dir immer in Dateien an.
Auf der linken Seite...
Ne, wobei, das war noch ein anderes Plugin.
Vergiss es.
Ja, HR-Leute sind immer ganz besonders speziell.
Wobei, der HR, der Personalabteilungstyp, der dabei war beim Vorstellungsgespräch, den fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Auch wenn er typische HR-Fragen gestellt hat.
Den fand ich nice.
Ja, ich glaube, da habe ich bei der Gamestar ein Testvideo gesehen.
War jetzt nicht so meins.
Hey Max, was kann ich gegen Fake-Follower machen? Werde schon seit drei Tagen von Fake-Followern auf Twitch verfolgt.
Moment.
Von was wirst du verfolgt?
Also, wenn du Fake gefollowt wirst auf Twitch.
Das räumt Twitch nach, also irgendwelche Follow-Bots räumt Twitch immer innerhalb von 1-2 Wochen auf.
Wenn dich Leute abfacken...
Dann kannst du ja einfach PN-Kommunikation unterbinden.
Ansonsten, wenn du Follower-Bots hast, das ist nicht schlimm.
Die löscht Twitch meistens nach 1-2 Wochen.
Ne, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ah, ist die Musik aus?
Bist du in 5 Monaten 30?
Wisst ihr, ich bin nächstes Jahr 40.
Was habt ihr für Monitoring an der Arbeit?
Das kann ich hier gar nicht so pauschal beantworten, weil da vieles historisch gewachsen ist.
Wir haben mehreres.
Es gibt Prometheus Grafana.
Es gibt auch noch ein Checkmk.
Es gibt auch noch ein Graphite oder sowas.
Es gibt noch ein InfluxDB für irgendwelche Windows-Kisten.
Es gibt einiges.
Hat mich auch einer gefragt.
Max, willst du nicht mal unser Grafana updaten auf neuestes Red Hat?
Habe ich auch gesagt, ja, mache ich, kein Problem.
Seitdem nie wieder darüber gesprochen.
Aber das mache ich wirklich.
Das würde ich wirklich machen.
Weil wir brauchen unbedingt eine neue Grafana-Version.
Weil die neuesten Grafana-Versionen können sich zu Google Managed Prometheus verbinden mit Google-Authentifizierung ohne Zwischenproxy.
Ja.
Einfach immer von Base-Touchen sprechen und die Manager mögen dich.
Ich denke mir einfach, dass das echt unser Key zum Success ist.
So sollten wir das machen.
Ja gut, es ist ein Unterschied.
Zwischen sich selbst fertig machen oder jeden Furz extrem zu loben.
Und viele Unternehmen neigen halt danach, permanent auf diese Wir-Feiern-Uns-Extrem-Ab-Schiene zu gehen.
Es hat ja keiner was dagegen, wenn was wirklich Cooles ist.
Dass man das ein bisschen breit tritt und zelebriert.
Aber es muss ja nicht alles sein.
Also mein aktueller Arbeitgeber, bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie schlimm die in dem Gesichtspunkt sind.
Aber mein letzter.
Das waren die Selbst-Feierungen in Person.
Moin Triton, schön, dass du da bist.
Exzellent.
Korrekt.
Kannst du mal einen Stable-Diffusion-XL-Stream machen?
Ne.
Keine Ahnung von.
Ich hatte letztens eine Sicherheits-Schulung für neue Mitarbeiter.
Und da war unter anderem das Thema, dass wir nicht einfach random USB-Sticks reinstecken sollen.
Und was auch noch Thema war.
Dass wir nicht einfach random USB-Sticks reinstecken sollen.
Komplett random.
Hat überhaupt nichts mit Technik und USB-Sticks zu tun gehabt.
Was auch noch Thema war ist.
Ähm.
Wenn es im Gebäude brennt.
Und ihr sicher rausgekommen seid.
Dann sagt doch bitte eurem jeweiligen Chef kurz Bescheid, dass ihr sicher das Gebäude.
Dass ihr lebend das Gebäude verlassen habt.
Wurde da erzählt.
Ja.
Aber ist ja auch irgendwie schon naheliegend.
Dass es den direkten Chef interessiert, ob alle seine Leute lebend aus dem Gebäude gekommen sind.
Oder nicht.
Oder dass irgendeiner drin ist und nicht rauskommt oder so.
Mit Kollegen zusammen Pause machen.
Ab und zu.
Also ich mach das so.
Ich mach das so.
Ihr wisst ich bin jetzt was.
Also ich halte so die Dosierung von Menschen auf einem Minimum.
Tagsüber.
Ja.
Also es muss nicht mehr sein.
Als notwendig.
Ich reiß mich da nicht unbedingt drum und lade irgendwelche Leute ein.
Aber.
Ab und zu gehe ich mit Leuten in die Kantine.
Die ich aus dem Projekt kenne.
Oder bei mir aus dem Team.
Allerdings.
Die allermeisten Fälle.
Time ich.
Meine Anwesenheit in Frankfurt.
In der Firma so.
Das das zusammen fällt.
Mit meinem Ex-Kollege.
Beziehungsweise jetzt wieder Kollege.
Den ich noch von der alten Firma kenne.
Und den ich quasi mitgebracht habe in die neue Firma.
Das wir beide zum gleichen Tag da sind.
Und dann gehen wir in Frankfurt immer Mittagspause.
Zu Mexikaner fressen.
Das ist quasi so 90% der Tage.
Wenn ich in Frankfurt bin.
Gehe ich mit meinem Kollege zusammen.
Zu Mexikaner futtern.
Und an anderen Tagen.
Gehe ich eventuell mal.
Wenn ich da bin.
Gehe ich eventuell mal mit Leuten aus dem Projekt.
Oder aus dem Team.
In die Kantine.
Oder ich hole mir beim Bäcker irgendwas.
Letzten zweimal habe ich beim Bäcker was geholt.
Und dann bin ich da.
Habe ich ein bisschen meine Ruhe.
Weil in der Kantine ist es auch immer übertrieben voll.
Wie ist die Kantine?
Ja die ist ein bisschen außerhalb.
Also außerhalb.
Man muss ein Stückchen laufen.
Aber das ist nicht.
Also ein Stückchen laufen.
Läuft 10 Minuten oder so.
Aber die ist nicht schlecht.
Die ist nicht so.
Die ist nicht so wie früher die.
Die Commerzbank Kantine.
Kennt noch irgend jemand.
Die alte Commerzbank Kantine in Frankfurt.
Die war eklig.
Die war richtig eklig.
Commerzbank Kantine Frankfurt.
Die.
Mal gucken ob es da auch Bilder von gibt.
The fuck.
Hauptbahnhof.
Ja.
Die war mal früher.
War die.
Bin mir gerade gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube der Willy Brandt Platz.
Kann irgendwo hier so früher gewesen sein.
Die alte Commerzbank Kantine.
Aber die gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr.
Irgendwo hier so.
So in diesem.
Grundkreis da.
Die war eklig.
Die war richtig eklig.
Meinst du die Kantine.
In.
In was?
Schreib das mal please aus.
Ich weiß nicht was gemeint ist damit.
So also.
Die war eklig.
Und nie wieder hin.
Nachdem.
Ich einmal da war.
Also ich war mehrfach da.
Aber ein neues Hochhaus.
Ne.
Die war die Kantine.
Die alte Kantine die ich meine.
Ich weiß.
Ich weiß wie ich das wieder finde.
Wo die war.
Da gab es so einen.
Toastbrot.
Shop unten drunter.
Ich habe vergessen.
Wie dieser Laden heißt.
Das war so ein.
Da gab es so getoastete Sandwiches.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Moment.
Hauptbahnhof.
Willy Brandt Platz.
Main Tower.
Es kann auch sein.
Das es das alles gar nicht mehr gibt.
Auf der Ecke war so ein ultra teures Restaurant.
Ne. Ne.
Das hieß anders.
Das muss.
Das muss hier.
Irgendwo hier muss das.
Zeit für Brot.
Irgendwo hier war das glaube ich früher.
Ist Street View up to date?
Warte mal.
Hier ist so ein super teures Restaurant.
Und.
Irgendwo hier ist das.
Ach keine Ahnung.
Das gibt es anscheinend.
Das hat wahrscheinlich alles Corona nicht überlebt.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest.
Äh.
Ja.
In die Richtung.
So.
Vielleicht wenn ich es sehe.
Galileo Hochhaus.
Galileo Kantine.
Das kann sein.
Ja.
So.
Das.
Genau.
Da ist was drinne.
Hier oder hier war.
Hier war die alte Kantine drinne.
Sieht man da hier.
Wie komme ich jetzt hier aus diesem Street View Geschiss wieder raus.
Nicht Hanau.
Frankfurt.
So.
Und da war.
Hier oben war irgendwie noch ne Commerzbank Kantine drinne.
Ich glaube das hieß wirklich Galileo Kantine Frankfurt oder so.
Ne. Nicht Galileo.
Zumindest war früher.
Letztendlich.
Komm mir egal.
Hier war früher ne Kantine drinne.
Im zweiten Stock.
Oder im ersten und zweiten Stock.
Von der Commerzbank.
Und die war richtig eklig.
Da hab ich mal nen Hähnchen gekriegt.
Also so ein Hähnchen Brustfilet.
Und als ich das umgedreht hab.
War das unten voll mit irgendwelchen Staubfusseln.
Die waren da drinne.
Einge.
Einfrittiert.
In der Hähnchen Brust.
Auf der unteren Seite.
Das war voller Staub.
Also so richtig zusammenhängende Staubfusseln.
So als hätte einer nen Lappen genommen.
Vom Abwaschen in der Küche.
Und hätte es.
Unter so nen Schnitzel gefäffert.
Und.
Das war richtig abartig.
Und das war das letzte Mal wo ich da war.
Ich war da relativ oft.
Einfach weil es billig war.
Und auch subventioniert war.
Und.
Weil ich bei der Commerzbank gearbeitet hab.
Man weiß ja nicht.
Zumindest.
War das ganz furchtbar eklig.
Es war aber billig.
Das beste in der Kantine damals war der Salat.
Die hatten so nen Salatbuffet.
Da konnte man sich richtig fett den Teller voll machen.
Da konnte man.
Da konnte man beispielsweise Schnitzel in den Salat schmeißen.
So richtig nice.
So.
Und jetzt noch kleiner Fun Fact.
Das ist schon verjährt.
Deswegen erzähl ich's jetzt.
Ich hab mitbekommen.
Das.
Wir hatten nen ehemaligen Kollege auf der alten Arbeit.
Und.
Das war so'n typischer.
So'n typischer. Wie soll ich sagen.
Typischer Feuerwehrmann.
Der war auch bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr.
Hat aber in der IT gearbeitet.
Hauptberuflich.
Und.
Der musste aus allem so'n bisschen.
So Wettkampf.
Wettstreit machen.
Und dann kam er in die Kantine.
Und ich klau den nen Schnitzel.
Ich satt. Hä bist du bescheuert?
Warum willst du den Schnitzel klauen?
Bist du total bescheuert?
Ich klau den nen Schnitzel.
Habe ich mir nix dabei gedacht.
So nach dem Motto.
Was auch immer.
Erzählt viel wenn der Tag lang ist.
Und ohne Scheiß.
Der Kerl hat sich.
Nen riesen Teller Nudel geholt.
Ist zur Kasse.
Also das habe ich im Nachhinein dann gecheckt.
Kommt mit nem riesen Teller Nudel an.
Und dann schiebt er die Nudel weg.
Und dann hat er halt nen Schnitzel drunter liegen.
Er hat quasi keine Ahnung.
2,50 für nen riesen Teller Nudel bezahlt.
Und dann hat er drinnen halt nen Schnitzel versteckt.
Wo ich auch glaube.
Meine Goethe alter.
Es ist jetzt nicht so das du kein Geld verdienst.
Das war so.
Keine Ahnung.
Niemand wollte es wissen.
Und niemand hat es interessiert.
Aber der wollte irgendwie Mutprobe machen.
Ich klaue denen heut nen Schnitzel.
Das ist schon ewig.
Das ist schon richtig lange her.
Der hat den irgendwie nen Schnitzel geklaut.
Unter seinen Teller Nudeln.
Unter seinen Tellern Nudeln.
eine Kantine hier. Meine Güte, also
keine Ahnung, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Der erzählt das
heute noch seinen Freunden. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Der ist mit dran schuld,
dass die Kantine nicht mehr da ist. Übrigens, wer hat
eben im Chat was geschrieben wegen der Kantine?
Da war Kantine.
Screw loose. Ich habe den Eindruck, du warst da auch schon
öfters. Seit wann gibt es die denn nicht mehr?
Ich war da jahrelang schon nicht mehr.
Übrigens, die Toastbrote
von denen, die sind echt nicht schlecht hier.
Die sind ein bisschen teuer
gewesen, damals schon.
Lasst uns mal gucken.
Ja genau, so sah das aus. Lasst uns mal
gucken, ob die eine Webseite
haben. Stonesfood.com
Ich will mal wissen, was
das heute...
Ich will mal wissen, was das heute
kostet. Genau.
Die machen so
Toastbrot-Dinger.
E-Mail?
Was?
Ich will
eine Speise, fucking Speisekarte haben,
Alter. Speisekarte hier.
Hier genau, Toasted.
Okay, es ist nicht so viel
teurer geworden, aber es ist teurer geworden.
Genau.
Also, Spicy Chicken
kannst du dir da grillen lassen.
Na gut, es ist schon
ordentlich. Früher weiß ich,
früher weiß ich noch, du hast ziemlich genau
5 Euro bezahlt.
Für so ein gegrilltes...
Nein, du gehst da hin und bestellst.
Musst dich per E-Mail bestellen. Heute
bezahlst du...
7 Euro für irgendwie so ein Spicy Chicken.
Und ich hab... Ich bin früher da immer mit
irgendwie 7 Euro raus.
Und ich hab immer nen...
Die hatten, die hatten glaube ich auch
Tiramisu... Ne, die hatten irgendwie so komischen
äh, so, so komischen
Joghurt oder so. Der hat auch mega nice
geschmeckt.
Da hab ich immer so einen Joghurt geholt
und hier so eins von diesen gegrillten
Dingern und da bin ich... Lucky Lux!
Boah, das hat früher 5 Euro oder sowas
gekostet. Ja, das ist ganz schön teuer geworden.
Boah, das ist extrem teuer geworden
eigentlich. Aber gut, ich war da auch schon
5 Jahre oder so nicht mehr.
So.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich drauf gekommen bin.
Achso, ja, mit Kollegen Pausen machen oder nicht.
Daher. Ja, wie gesagt.
Ich mach eigentlich immer mit
einem Kollegen Pause, nämlich den, den ich schon
lange kenn. Und ansonsten geh ich auch ab und zu
mal mit anderen in die Kantine oder hol mir irgendwas
vom Bäcker.
Bei der Zwischenprüfung muss das Berichtsheft aktuell sein. Okay.
Die haben daraus gelernt, dass es zu viele
Leute so gemacht haben wie ich.
Ich hab bis zur Abschlussprüfung keine
Ausbildungsberichte geschrieben.
Verständlich. Lernt man
immer noch UML? Ich glaube,
glaube schon, ja.
Ich musste nicht einmal was in UML machen.
In all den Jahren.
Also ich bin 40 Minuten mit dem Chat hinten dran.
Ich muss mich jetzt beeilen.
Wird nicht bei der prüflichen, mündlichen Prüfung nach Themen aus den
Berichten gesucht.
Es wird bei der mündlichen Prüfung nach allen möglichen
Sachen gesucht. Eigentlich sollten die sich bei der mündlichen Prüfung
auf deinen Abschluss
ähm,
Thema beziehen.
Aber wenn sie davon keine Ahnung haben,
fragen sie dich in random Sachen.
Also ehemaliger mit Azubi von mir.
Der hat.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, was der, was der gemacht hat.
Als Abschlussprojekt.
Was hat der gemacht?
Der hat irgendeine VM gestartet auf seinem Notebook in der Abschluss
Präsentation.
Das weiß ich.
Ich glaube, Loadbalancer.
Ich glaube, der hat irgendwas Loadbalancer mäßig gemacht.
Ich glaube, der hat irgendwas Loadbalancer mäßig gezeigt in der Abschlussprüfung.
So, zumindest da hat er erzählt, ähm, auf den hier auf den System
lockt man sich per SSH ein und dann wurde er tatsächlich in dem in
diesem Fachgespräch von der Abschlussprüfung gefragt, auf
welcher Schicht des OSI Modells arbeitet SSH oder welches Netzwerk
Protokoll benutzt SSH?
Und da hat er gesagt Ja, Moment, SSH ist das Protokoll.
Nein, nein, das meinen sie nicht.
Sie meinen etwas tiefer.
Wie sieht es der OSI Schicht und so, den müssen sie total verwirrt haben.
Und am Ende wollten sie darauf raus, dass das was auf TCP Basis ist, so Stepsmokes.
Bist du noch am Start?
Ich bin jetzt leider erst ein bisschen später bei dir am angekommen im Chat.
Halte für den Fall, der fällt das noch am Start, bis wenn ich ich ich lese trotzdem
mal durch und sag was zu.
Also, hey Max, ich bin 28 Jahre alt.
In meinem Leben hab ich nicht viel viel erreicht.
Kein Studium und abgebrochene Ausbildung im Handwerk.
Mach dir nichts draus.
So sah es bei mir auch aus.
Ich und ich war zwar noch nicht ganz 28, aber ich war auch schon älter.
Ich war wann hab ich angefangen mit YouTube Leute 2010?
Also war ich 26.
Da war die Ausbildung aber schon mehr oder weniger durch.
Sie war noch mal drei Jahre ab.
Oder zwei.
Ja, sagen wir mal, ich war so 24, 25 damals, wo ich mit 24 glaube ich oder mit mit 24 habe
ich glaube ich die meine meine Physi Ausbildung dann gemacht.
Also macht ihr bis dahin schon mal nichts draus.
Das war bei mir auch so.
Ich habe auch eine andere Ausbildung angefangen, nämlich im BWL Bereich.
Ich weiß, kann man sich bei mir kaum vorstellen, aber ist so, habe ich ja auch schon ein paar
Mal erzählt.
Und ich habe mir davon auch nichts mehr gemerkt, wie gesagt, außer die Buchhalter Nase und
die
Ausbildung.
Und die Ausbildung.
Ich habe mich da schon mal mit dem BWL Bereich.
Ich habe mich da schon mal mit dem BWL Bereich angefragt.
Und die Ausbildung war schon ganz, ganz linear und degressiv abschreiben.
Wobei ich gehört habe, degressiv abschreiben kann man nicht mehr.
Ja, also bei mir sah es genauso an.
Ich möchte mich Richtung IT, wer einsteigen?
Was ich möchte.
Was ich möchte mich Richtung IT, wer einsteigen?
Was ich möchte mich.
Okay, du willst quer Einsteiger werden.
Ja, ich hab bisher nur Absagen bekommen, weil ich keine Berufserfahrung an dieser Bar.
Ja, gut, das ist auch schwierig.
Sich auch flirten.
Ich habe bisher nur Absagen bekommen, weil ich keine Berufserfahrung an dieser Bar habe.
sich auf eine nicht ausbildungsstelle zu bewerben
ohne
vorweisbare erfahrung ja das ist tatsächlich nicht ohne es ist ja auch in irgendeiner art und weise nachvollziehbar
dass die leute in das
die wollen halt zumindest sicher gehen dass du der sache gewachsen bist
es bringt ja auch nichts muss ich das muss es ja auch aus unternehmenssicht sehen es bringt ja auch nichts irgendeiner hinzusetzen
für job x
von dem du dir überhaupt nicht sicher sein kannst dass der
dass der alles kann was für job x erforderlich ist
alle unternehmen die in meiner stadt sind suchen quereinsteiger schreiben die vielleicht aber wollen da nicht was lieber als was lieber
quereinsteiger suchen ist
jemand der einen anderen job bisher hatte aber
der entweder nicht allzu weit weg davon ist
oder
der vielleicht schon im alten job
obwohl eine andere job bezeichnung in der richtung was gemacht hat oder der in irgendeiner art und weise mit
projekten und sachen und technologien schon vertraut ist die dort benutzt werden
also
so als jemand der nichts vorzuweisen hat
Ich weiß hast du denn was vorzubewegen weiß gar nicht ob du bist wieder da sehr schön
hast du hast du irgendwann hast du erfahrung vor zwei sachen hast du beispielsweise in github account wurde projekte zeigen kannst kannst du irgendwie
berichten so nach dem motto ja ich habe schon die und die
cluster aufgebaut da und da linux mäßig was war ein bisschen was vorweisen musste schon können
weil die müssen ja auch sicherstellen dass sie irgendeiner hinsetzen der weiß was er macht
du bist ja nicht auf der ausbildungsstelle sondern auf den ganz normalen job
aber wenn man sich manche stellenanzeigen
anschaut suchen die nach bill gates
der alles kann wie müsste also
das einfachste dürfte wahrscheinlich echt sein
da bist du auch mit 23 jahren nicht zu alt du suchst du eine ausbildung als
fisi oder fachinformatik anwendungsentwicklung oder du machst
eine umschulung zum fisi das geht auch das ist wenn du die ausbildung fertig
hast es ist egal das ist aber insofern ein bisschen ein bisschen schwieriger
weil ich kenne einen der macht so eine umschulung und der hat du musst du musst
am ende für diese umschulung dass du zugelassen wirst der abschlussprüfung
glaube ich ein dreivierteljahr praktikum machen und dort praktikumsplätze zu
finden für ein abschlussprojekt quasi für so das letzte dreivierteljahr einer
fisi-umschulung das ist relativ schwierig weil das wenige unternehmen
machen aber das kann man machen ja also das
allereinfachste wird wahrscheinlich wirklich sein du machst noch mal eine
ausbildung und das ist nicht keine schande mit mit 28 nochmal ausbildung zu
machen wenn du plan schon ein bisschen in dem bereich hast verkürzt du das
ganze insgesamt vielleicht
sogar noch um ein halbes oder oder um ein jahr und dann bist du mit 30 fertig
also dass das beste wäre tatsächlich machst du eine ausbildung das wäre
zumindest wahrscheinlich das einfachste für den einstieg ja wenn du natürlich
jetzt schon irgendwelche tollen projekte vorzuweisen hast eben in gut gefüllten
github account dich auskennst in allen möglichen bereichen da muss man halt
schauen dass du das ordentlich verkauft aber wenn du halt noch gar nichts
vorzuweisen hast ist natürlich als quereinsteiger schwierig weil mit was
willst du dann quereinsteigen wo ich mal kurz im chat gucken ob er was
geschrieben hat außer dass er wieder da ist ja du möchtest in die richtung sap
ok jeder was ihm gefällt okay da ich schon mal mit diesem system gearbeitet
habe in meiner alten handwerksfirma also ganz ehrlich du wirst kein sap
berater nur weil du in der in der alten handwerksfirma mal irgendwann in sap
rum geklickt hast das muss man an der stelle so klar sagen ich habe gar keine
ahnung was ein guter weg ist um sap berater zu werden
ich vermute mal dass die sap berater unter anderem mit werden willst weil sap
berater den ruf haben relativ viel zu verdienen
ich weiß es nicht ich habe auch keine ahnung wie man guten einstieg finden als
sap berater da kann ich dir kann ich dir nichts zu
sagen wenn das natürlich was ist was dir
gefällt du wirst sicherlich arbeitgeber finden die sap machen aber entweder
müssten die dich halt ausbilden oder eben irgendwo muss man sich die sap berater
es ja lernen. Und ja, auch wenn der Chat jetzt
sagt, die meisten SAP-Berater haben keinen Plan,
die werden doch etwas mehr Plan
von SAP haben, als man hat mal ein bisschen
drin rumgeklickt. Also entweder
machst du eine Umschulung,
ich meine,
von Null auf SAP-Berater,
weiß ich nicht, vielleicht
sucht irgendein Unternehmensberatungs
Personal,
Verschacherungsunternehmen
jemand, den sie gut verkaufen können
und die
frisieren halt deinen Lebenslauf so krass,
dass dich irgendjemand einkauft und
du lernst
nebenbei so viel so schnell,
dass du die überzeugen kannst, du hast
Ahnung, das ist aber alles eher
so ein, ja,
könnte und
hätte vielleicht,
also ich weiß nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man
SAP-Berater wird, das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Wie du im IT-Bereich anfangen kannst,
mit 28 kannst du auch noch eine Ausbildung machen
oder du machst eine Umschulung und guckst,
dass du irgendwie einen ordentlichen
Praktikumsplatz kriegst, dass du dann
ein Abschlussprojekt machen kannst.
Also der Einstieg ist mit einer Ausbildung tatsächlich am
einfachsten. Und du findest mit
28 ohne Probleme eine Ausbildung.
Viele freuen sich sogar, wenn die Azubis ein bisschen
älter sind.
Nicht alle, manche denken, die müssen jung sein, dass man
ihnen noch ordentlich was aufs Ohr erzählen kann.
Aber viele wissen das auch
zu schätzen, wenn man ein bisschen älter ist. Und die Ausbildung
kannst du in zwei Jahren fertig haben, easy.
Wenn du zackig bist.
ABAP ist eine
Strecksprache, ja, das habe ich auch schon öfters gehört.
Die Beispiele, die ich gesehen
habe, haben mich jetzt auch
nicht so begeistert bisher.
Welches Desktop-Environment fändest du
unter Linux? Als erstes
muss ich natürlich sagen, es ist Arch Linux, nicht
einfach nur Linux. Arch, by the way,
das ist i3.
i3WM
auf X
noch, nix Wayland.
Weil i3 gibt es ja auch für Wayland gar nicht.
Aber Wayland funktioniert in der VM nicht gescheit.
Und wenn nicht gescheit, meine ich nicht.
Es refresht den Screen nicht.
Und ich meine nicht ein
FPS, ich meine 0 FPS, der Screen refresht
nicht.
Und ein Screen, der nicht refresht,
kann auch nichts anzeigen.
Ja, nee, so habe ich das nicht gemeint. Ich weiß,
das ist jetzt schon eine halbe Stunde her.
So habe ich das nicht gemeint. Ich meine nicht,
dass du zu allem
bedingungslos Ja sagen sollst. Du machst
das alles.
Aber es ist durchaus sinnvoll zu sagen, ja, kann ich
machen, erklär's mir aber erstmal, zeig's
mir erstmal, anstatt gleich anzufangen
zu diskutieren, so nach dem Motto, ach, nee,
und von dem
System habe ich doch keine Ahnung und das ist doch
nicht mein Fachgebiet und außerdem ist das doch
eh was anderes.
Erstmal sagen, ja, kann ich mir angucken,
erklär mir das und danach
kann ich das machen, wenn das alles
passt. Und wenn du zu viele Sachen hast,
die du machen sollst,
das ist heute auch eines der ersten Sachen, die ich bei
meinem Chef gesagt habe, so nach dem Motto, hier, aktuell
mache ich 80% des Projektes.
Wenn ich noch irgendeinen anderen Service mitmachen soll,
dann muss man gucken, wie man das zeitlich
unter einen Hut kriegt. Im Zweifelsfall
muss ich dann,
müsst ihr euch ausdenken, was ich weniger
machen soll. Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Man sollte nicht immer zu allem Ja sagen.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man im Hinterkopf
die Verpflichtung verspürt, auch alles
machen zu müssen. Man kann
zu allem Ja sagen und wenn es zu
viel wird, geht man zu seinem Chef
und sagt, ja, also eigentlich
müsste ich jetzt das, das, das und das machen,
aber ich kann nur eins davon machen, was soll ich
denn machen? Dafür ist
die Führungskraft da.
Man kann das durchaus auf die
ab,
abwälzen, diese, diese Probleme,
weil das ist ihr Job, sich um sowas zu kümmern,
unter anderem. Und wenn ein Chef
sagt, ja, weiß ich auch nicht, da kannst
du immer noch vorschlagen, gut,
dann mache ich das so, wie ich es für richtig halte.
Aber wenn sich einer beschwert, dann schicke ich ihn zu dir.
Und das klappt. Das habe ich bei mir in der alten Arbeit
gesehen.
Wenn die Leute zu dir kommen und sagt Max,
kannst du mal das und das machen? Ich schreibe
dir dann zurück. Geht gerade nicht. Ich muss gerade
hier irgendwie
deploymen.
Machen oder sowas und ich habe keine Zeit und
die schreiben dann im zehn Minuten Takt hier
kannst jetzt mal gucken, dann schreibe ich da
nochmal. Ich habe doch geschrieben, ich habe keine
Zeit. Ich sage dir nachher, ich sage dir nachher
Bescheid, wenn ich durch bin. Und wenn sie dann
immer noch nicht nerven, sagst du halt Leute, ich
habe keine Zeit. Ich antworte jetzt nicht mehr
drauf. Wenn, wenn ihr irgendwas anderes wollt, geht
zu meinem Chef. Und ich kann es an einer Hand
abzählen. Von den ganzen Malen, wo ich gesagt
habe, geht jetzt nicht.
Und wenn es echt Probleme macht, geht zu meinem
Chef. Ich kann seine eine Hand abzählen, wo wirklich
mal jemand zu meinem Chef gegangen ist, weil es so
wichtig war. Und dann kam der im Zweifelsfall
vorbei. Die haben angerufen und ja, okay, dann
sucht euch aus. Was davon soll ich machen? Soll
ich das Deployment jetzt abbrechen und es andere
machen? Wenn du sagst, ich soll das machen, ist
kein Problem, mache ich. Aber dann wird nicht
deployed. Und meistens lief es dann darauf raus
so nach dem Motto. Dann okay, ich guck mal, wer noch
Zeit hat. Mach erst mal dein Deployment fertig.
Oder ja, könnt ihr nicht noch warten bis nach dem
Deployment und da ging das auch. Man so was muss
man sogar auf seinen Chef abwälzen. Dafür ist
er da. Dann muss ich da echt nicht mehr Stress
machen wie ohne und ohne Mist. Auch so eine Sache
plant euch ordentlich Pufferzeit ein. Wenn ihr
denkt, dass die Pläne habe ich in der Viertelstunde
durch sagt ihr braucht ne Stunde für wahrscheinlich.
Wenn irgendwas blödes ist, braucht ihr auch ne
Stunde für Wahrscheinlich.
was ganz blödes ist, sogar noch länger.
Weil es gibt
nichts Blöderes, wie wenn du jemandem sagst,
ach, ich mach noch kurz die Bläumen fertig, in 5
Minuten melde ich mich und
dann hört er in einem halben Tag
nichts von dir. Also gleich
am besten sagen, hier, Vormittag bin ich mit die Bläumen
beschäftigt. Da kommt erst gar keiner.
Und wenn dann das nach
5 Minuten fertig ist, dann ist gut. Da kann man immer noch
sagen, ja, Jungs, ging schneller.
Man muss mit der Zeit echt
ein bisschen
abgehärtet werden gegen
Leute, die permanent was
wollen. Im Zweifelsfall musst du die zum
Chef schicken. Und dafür ist
er da. Du bist für die Technik
da, dein Chef ist für die Organisation da.
Und wenn es Sachen gibt, wo du gerade nicht organisieren
kannst selbst, dann schick die zum Chef.
Oder zum Projektleiter, oder wer auch immer in dem
Fall da, der richtig ist.
130 Beats, danke für den Sub.
Moin, Kyoto Käse.
Ich glaube, das wird heute mit dem
Chat nix mehr.
Bin 40 Minuten hinten dran.
Das wird so gut bezahlt. Sie meint, unsere Bereitschaft,
ich kann dir nicht genau
sagen, was wir pro Stunde für die Bereitschaft
kriegen, also
nicht, weil ich es nicht sagen darf,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich es nicht sagen darf, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen
anteilig was
für die Bereitschaft und
wir kriegen
150 oder 200 Prozent oder so
für Wochenendeinsätze.
Irgendwie so, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Keine Ahnung. Zumindest
ich habe letztens eine Abrechnung gesehen
von
jemand anderem, der hatte
Wochenendeinsatz und Bereitschaft.
Der hat knapp 1000 Euro am Wochenende verdient.
Ohne groß was zu machen.
Das ist wirklich so.
Wie hat man wie hat man aus Spaß einer gesagt?
Infinite Money Klitsch.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, als reiße ich mich da drum.
Die wollen ja, dass ich das mache.
Aber mal aus Business Sicht.
Ja, aus Business Sicht macht es natürlich Sinn.
Leute, das ist ja kein
wir verschenken Geld.
Das habe ich schon oft genug erzählt.
Solche Sachen sind durchkalkuliert.
Die überlegen sich,
okay,
wir haben so und so wichtige,
wir haben diese und diese wichtigen Services.
Wenn diese Services ausfallen,
bedeutet das im Durchschnitt
einen finanziellen Verlust
oder einen finanziellen Schaden von, keine Ahnung,
500.000 Euro
pro Stunde Ausfall.
Und das rechnen die dann hoch und sagen,
okay, wir hoffen ja nicht, dass das passiert.
Aber wenn wir jemanden in Bereitschaft haben
und für den Fall der Fälle, dass es doch alle,
was weiß ich, zwei, drei Jahre mal ein bisschen ruckelt,
ist er da auch nachts um drei und der kann das fixen
bis morgen die morgens die Börse aufmacht.
Versus wir verlieren zwei.
Das war zumindest früher bei der Bank so.
Keine Ahnung, wir verlieren irgendwie zwei Tage an der Börse,
wo sie handeln können oder sowas.
Das sind Millionenverlust.
Versus du bezahlst einen Typ ordentlich fürs Nichtstun.
Und irgendjemand hat das kalkuliert und gesagt,
hey, es lohnt sich, unsere Leute fürs Nichtstun zu bezahlen,
weil für den seltenen Fall der Fälle,
das wirklich mal was ist,
sparen wir so viel Geld, dass sich das wieder lohnt.
Und deswegen werden,
in so einem Bereich halt Bereitschaft gemacht,
in dem eigentlich nie was passiert,
aber nur für den Fall der Fälle lohnt sich trotzdem.
Was hältst du von dem Lizenzwechsel von Terraform?
Ich kann diesen Riesenaufschrei darum nicht wirklich verstehen.
Terraform kann weiterhin benutzt werden.
Das Einzige, was du nicht machen kannst,
ist quasi mit Terraform ein Konkurrenzprodukt zu Terraform bauen.
Ja, mir ist klar, dass es ganz streng genommen,
keine cleane Open-Source-Lizenz im Sinne der Open-Software-Foundation
oder wie die heißen ist,
weil du eben nicht free bist,
alles zu machen, was du willst.
Aber so den Riesenaufschrei und wir forken Terraform und so,
ich, ich fühl's noch nicht, wie man so schön sagt.
Hast du eigentlich schon mal was mit Redis gemacht?
Ja, aber nicht so, dass ich mich damit groß auskennen würde.
Welche Sprache hat kein Debugger?
Gibt's bestimmt welche.
Brainfuck oder so.
Gibt es, also C++ hat welche.
Gibt es, gibt es gescheite C++-Debugger,
die keine IDE-Integration sind?
Bestimmt, ich mein C++ ist eines der verbreitetsten Sprachen,
allerdings auch eines der beschissensten Sprachen.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Tools schlecht sein müssen.
Seniorenheld, danke für den Sub.
Ich glaube, den hab ich gesehen.
Das hat auf irgendeinem Artikel verlinkt.
Ich glaube, ich hab sogar den Artikel,
das war ein ziemlich kleiner Blog-Eintrag nur,
auf den er verlinkt hat, gell?
Relativ kurz und knackig.
Ich, ich krieg's aber nicht mehr zusammen.
Wie weit hast du bis zweimal im Monat vor Ort?
Ich bin ungefähr einmal die Woche in Frankfurt.
Spätestens alle zwei Tage.
Das ist so.
Spätestens alle zwei Wochen.
Alle eins bis zwei Wochen.
Alle zwei Wochen bin ich auf jeden Fall da,
weil da ist dienstags immer riesen Meeting-Tag.
Da war ich auch schon.
Die sind nice.
Äh, die heißen irgendwas Feinkost oder sowas, gell?
Ja.
Die sind, die sind nice und zwar,
wo wir grad bei Pepo, Pepo Fett in, in Frankfurt sind,
die sind nice, die haben richtig gute Sandwiches
und die haben mega nicen
Nudelsalat mit Tomaten, mit so getrocknetem Tomaten-Zeug drin.
Und, und die haben auch so Joghurt mit Kirschen-Zeug und so drin,
das ist auch gut.
Aber, wobei, ist das der?
Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Doch, doch, ich glaub, das ist, das sind die.
Ich, wobei ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher bin,
ob ich den nicht verwechsel.
Doch, da kann man oben, oben sitzen, oder?
Die haben oben so ne, so ne Etage, wo man noch sitzen kann.
Ja, da kann man oben sitzen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's das, das ist, was ich meine.
Egal, genug Frankfurt, Pepo, Fett.
Gleiches Bad-Getime, ja.
Ja, Street View wurde wieder geupdatet.
Er wollte halt mal nen Schnitzel klauen, der Typ, ja.
Ah, du bist auch weg.
Auf welches Jahr bezieht sich die 5 Euro?
Boah, das ist schon lange her.
2017 oder so?
Ja, die wissen's halt nicht besser.
Mario, danke für den Sub.
Proc-Subscription.
Nice.
Da kann ich dir nix zu sagen.
Drei ESP286 in der Post bekommen.
Was hast du vor, was willst du machen?
ESP32 bieten sich eigentlich mittlerweile fast mehr an.
Die sind etwas potenter als die ESP2866.
Aber je nachdem, was man machen will.
Manchmal ist auch eine ESP2866 Pflicht.
Nee, du bist nicht zu alt dafür.
Wie gesagt, ich war auch...
Ich hab auch schon ne Ausbildung davor gemacht.
Hat kein Studium und sonst was.
Ich war zwar noch nicht ganz 28,
aber ich war auch schon ein bisschen älter als Amos.
Also, du bist auch bei weitem nicht der Einzige.
Das wirst du auch, falls du ne Ausbildung machst
und noch in die Berufsschule geschickt wirst und sowas.
Und du dann da auch wirklich hingehst.
Was ja nicht wirklich zwingend erforderlich ist.
Wirst du das auch sehen.
Du hast noch mehr, die älter sind.
So, Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Recht spontane Geschichte heute wieder gewesen.
Und wir haben eigentlich nur 2 Stunden sinnlos rumgeschwätzt.
So wie das sein muss.
Richtiger White-Pepo-Happy-Stream.
Ab 22 Uhr lief die Hälfte.
Vielleicht morgen, können wir mal gucken.
Ich seh das, ab 22 Uhr liefen immer die Hälfte der Zuschauer.
Okay, ein Drittel der Zuschauer lief instant 22 Uhr.
Versteh ich aber.
Weil Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Denen geht's genauso wie mir.
Aber ich geh jetzt pennen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns, beziehungsweise nicht ganz richtig.
Wir hören uns.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.